wow great and how many times you do
that oh hey guys hey everybody Welcome
everybody it's
Monday the uh what what what year is it
it's the 24th the year of Our Lord 24th
year and it is the month is February the
5th and it is a rainy day out here in La
it is that's my line it's a rainy day
Los Angeles and we're joined by friend
of the show Mark ruier who has uh back
in town hey everybody we'll be sitting
in with us today we have so many great
things to discuss thank you Lena how
have you been my friend I've been great
my dude I um I've been great I've been
spending time in New York and uh I just
made a road trip I was telling you from
there to here which is Los Angeles on
this rainy day um it's a rainy day out
Angeles here in Los
Angeles it's my line is it it's what I'm
known for that's a good it's really good
play it's a rainy day out here in Los
Angeles that's me
wa how do you come up with it God damn I
don't know man it's just it's just
you're born with it or you're not that's
incredible stuff you so you drove from
New York yeah I drove from New York and
I made some stops along the way and uh
yeah played some shows i' played some
shows for strangers on the street and
and live stream those are your roots
yeah man yeah feels good to get out
there with the people yeah it does it
does yeah it's nice cuz it's like you
don't thank you so much they're yeah the
people are pleased they're very pleased
yeah it's just the there's it's like the
energy of playing to people who are not
interested in seeing you versus like a
hard ticket room is different and nice
you know it's like you have to earn
people's attention and so anyway
it's probably nice seeing people like
thrown off like what is this and then
they're like oh I like this yeah yeah
and kids too you there's like a lot of
like just great material with you have
beautiful hazel eyes did you know that
do I really yeah really green guys
please guys let me see these here let me
put you want to check these out up close
can me get a closeup please okay okay go
ahead did you know you have beautiful
hazel eyes well I knew the inside was
it's on my license okay what does your
license say oh wow it says HZ or it or
Oh that's oh dude I think he's got the
real Hazel I think y are my fellow Hazel
brother you damn you're a bro I sure am
he's not wait what wait we did there was
a we don't need all the lore but let me
get a closeup of your eye okay there's a
lot of lore here yeah back story stay
still oh
yeah is the lighting good enough to
really get the flash your ey is that
okay yeah yeah yeah go ahead okay Dan
why are you you fronting with hazel
what's going he's doing stolen Hazel
Valor no I'm not I have blue hazel eyes
it's a it's a subtype of Hazel that
Ethan refuses to
recognize let me do one without the
flash so blue oh yeah this these are
perfect so here's one and one without
and we'll we'll pull it up for the
people at home to see okay it's good to
include the people at home in this kind
of stuff well that's the point right
yeah I guess I suppose it is it wouldn't
be very good show if you're were just
having secret conversation
think is like and that's why I'm the
best of what I do yeah all right I sent
you those beautiful Hazel
Congratulations by the way thank you so
much I appreciate it but that's gorgeous
look at that nice wow Franklin and to be
honest they don't even okay hold on one
second they don't even show as well as
they look in person they're more green
looking in person I don't inspected my
eye my Iris like this well I inside
it'sit a brown apparently Hazel is the
rarest eyee color really a true Hazel no
you call this a true Hazel in my
opinion in my expert opinion if this
isn't Hazel then I don't know what the
is
brother you said it yeah so um uh before
we get started we have so much to talk
about I hope you're excited are you up
to date with your um internet te you
know what I did a little bit of
preliminary research okay good um and I
understand there's things going on with
the ace family true uh I understand
there are things going on with uh Brett
Cav not Brett
cavana not I understand Cav Harvey
Weinstein Harvey wait
what no no no
not with Ryan Kavanaugh Ryan Kavanaugh
who you've had a beef with for a long
time guy that's a way to put it
he's suing me like four times I mean
that's that's that's like real Jesus is
that beef I mean that's real beef yeah
that's that's legal beef that's like
real Street beef and it's white collar
beef I guess is what it is yeah I
suppose that's true yeah what else is
going on in the world in this uh well
I'll tell you okay but first let me tell
you about this new Teddy fresh jacket
that was just
released today it's a module
denim um jacket with all these different
zippers I have a video I'd like to show
you you guys holy
jack it off the middle Zips and
then the bottom part comes off I'll show
you a video that exemplifies it uh
better that's pretty cool I
agree I thought I think there was a
really sweet piece they made very uh
Innovative I mean I haven't seen
anything like it I know people will be
like dude you haven't seen this bro
this is from like Stuy 20 97 you
Haw like all right I don't
know as far as I know so yeah check it
out here you can turn off the we made a
nice ASMR video check this out who
wow feel the
tingles not only is it module it's
reversible too oh yeah it's like 20
different jackets
GOP
yeah there it goes the sounds are really
selling it is good those there's also
wait excuse me the emblem in script is
very elegant is that a new um it's
newish I mean it's something we've been
we've been using for for a little while
not super super old pretty sexy but
that's that is a reversible module
jacket my friends and I'll tell you what
else if you go to Teddy fresh.com
that's dope for the uh most ADV
adventurous of
y'all there's two colorways you can
modulate them both together into
different colors and patterns and what
whatever the flipping heck you want to
do with this so that's like Ultron dude
it is it's an Ultron of of of uh jackets
holy Christ and it's going to save us
from the all
spark did I do that right um
noon what's the all spark allspark is uh
that's from Transformers what what did
you say I said Voltron oh Voltron Power
Rangers that's the no oh my God I feel
like these are interchangeable Worlds
how is Transformers not whatever you
said Voltron because Voltron has to come
together Vol Voltron those are they are
piloted Mecca there are human pilots in
it whereas the Transformers they
are transform I mean they come together
they can we've seen it but not really
what do I thought that was our whole
thing do Transformers come together
you're about to get some rule some uh
rule 34 is Voltron Mech war is uh
um the uh
you thinking of a Megazord I'm thinking
of megazord yeah Megazord Power Rangers
yes that would work oh my okay hold on
trans it's not understanding my question
at all do the
Transformers robots ever
morph together I mean that's combin
there there may have been in there has
been
in research absolutely yeah that's
that's all for you you can even throw
stuff on the screen if you want holy
there's a part in the Michael Bay
films where Optimus takes a Decepticon
wings or some that's but I was
thinking something more thorough
combiner yeah this is this is a niche
thing but you're you're technically
correct over the course of their endless
Wars the cybertronian race has developed
a frightful array of weapons but the
most powerful and versatile invention of
all might be the power of physical
physically merging multiple
cybertronians into a single form that is
that
I mean you know what I'm saying the the
Superion is five Autobots put together
wow that's just like a Autobot orgy
though I don't think it's
like all right those robots are just
they're just having sex hold on
let me type Superion before you all
start hating Superion Transformers let's
see what this are these
robots having sex that's a good question
they how else do they reproduce
where's the penis do that do that trans
wherever you want yeah exactly it's
wherever you want it pipe of the I know
where the uh I know where the female
part is the gas
tank or or we've seen the exhaust pipe
is also a hole oh that can be
accessed kind of stuff it uh-huh stuff
it in there so this is the this is them
all combined together you guys listen I
uh I I see the point the Transformers
clearly do combine uh it there is still
the distinction of the Voltron robots
being piloted by humans whereas these
sent unto themselves but okay there's no
okay that's that's the difference right
there so are all the Transformers
together determining the movement of
this super beast or is there one I think
it's just who's the main guy Optimus
Prim he takes Direct Control yeah okay
yeah yeah because you can't have that
many Chef that's a good question though
too many cooks too many cooks and also
those guys what are you going to do
bumblebee was he going to control the
superon give me
a right give me
exact let's go over there all right so
we got us so much to get to hey check
this out Studio City this morning I
don't know if people out of La probably
don't know or care but we've had like
apoc apocalyptic rain happening here
yeah
apparently uh last night for like a 6-h
hour period was the most rain LA's ever
got no in a 6-h hour period no
it's still raining by the way it's
raining pretty significantly it's a
rainy day here in Los
oh L it's a rainy day out here Angeles
I'm so sorry um yeah apparently the
storm stalled out over LA and it's
raining even more than anticipated but
here is the um LA River which is usually
a Barren Wasteland a gorgeous landmark
and I saw people going why do they build
it so big like there's never any rain
but here check this out okay hear him in
Studio City look at that that's insane I
have never seen
the LA River for any River anywhere in
the world that's
insane River
I mean yeah it doesn't you know
it's clean it's all clean in the city I
guess for people that aren't from La
these channels are how deep would you
say probably like 20 ft probably even
deeper
like extremely deep right and I've never
seen it pull up a picture of it empty
yeah R coffee that's their new
cappuccino just take a
dunk here you go sh but yeah and know La
we we love you know how we have a
drought here all the time and so
capturing rainwater is so important for
us and that's why all this goes out to
the ocean actually yeah that is so isn't
that nice look at all this fresh water
yeah this gives you an impression the
Pacific Ocean see you later it's going
to it I was talking yesterday about how
up the infrastructure here is
it's really not built to handle this
like every curb is up to the sidewalk is
water you have to like you have to be an
Olympian to get around like absolutely
yeah the I mean the city floods when
there's extreme here it is uh this is a
great oh yeah good good thinking cam but
I've seen po points where I feel like
it's bigger it's definitely deeper in
different areas but yeah this but it
usually looks like this and you're like
what's the deal what what the is
the point of this I'll be back so good
job La good job mayor whoever built that
baby that's a wonderful River beautiful
River it is it is and here's another
shot this is me trying to um keep dry
over this rainy day you know what I'm
saying yeah trying to keep dry out here
oh man in this rainy Los Angeles day you
look good
brother uh let's see that's you running
from Optimus we have another graphic
here California faces severe crisis as a
dangerous atmospheric River storm brings
torrential rain is this from today cuz
my brother was oh yeah this is from
today so the storm is going to get it's
going to intensify again there's
atmospheric Rivers forming bro
yo I'm seeing that it broke a record uh
that was set previously in
1927 Wow Let's Go Global Climate Change
100 years 100 years 100 year flood
that's nuts dude but I feel like
these I mean people always say but
there's definitely some weather
anomalies hitting Los
Angeles that seem rare like recently we
had like an alltime rain event too
really just this I feel like this year
this
winner so oh Trisha's trending what the
let's see what's happening yes wait
do you do you know anything about this I
do yeah we know we know why you're
laughing King Charles about to be no no
I know and she she tweeted out literally
no
comment oh no okay so wait wait okay
hold on because they announced and Brace
yourselves for those at home that aren't
aware yet um but the Buckingham Palace
has announced that King Charles has
cancer no get
yeah have a moment silence I knew
that those fingers were not normal you
seen his fingers no they're like juicy
pigs in a blankie was this the
is is King Charles the diddler did he
didd or that's no that's his brother
that's his brother oh okay we sure know
diddling I mean not we're not actually I
mean are we are you sure of anything
yeah how can you disapprove
that there's plenty of photos of him
with uh Jimmy savil too so they were
very they were very close well there you
go Jesus they were very close Charles
smoking cigars and visiting children in
hospitals unimportant anyway so Trisha's
first baby was born
right as the queen died and people were
saying that that baby was a
Reincarnation of the queen but now with
her second child on the way it looks
like King Charles about to kick the
bucket as they
say and uh get in the box there with his
dearly departed mother I love this trend
of people dying coinciding with like
birthdays and The Reincarnation meme
it's great it's the whole royal family
is going to be in their their
whole
lineages
oh my God number one trending King
Charles number two
Trish okay I'll uhri is pregnant again
YouTube personality announces She is
expecting baby number two wait we knew
this is old news what is this hallmar
card this old you know who this is right
no that's ela's
brother oh still it's current they
have two kids or they're about to have
two kids God willing you I wish them
wish them
a birthing whatever he looks so much
like Brad the bull yeah I'm a nuts where
are things with that with the Trish and
you and the how are what's the deal
there well the deal is that we're not
really in in contact okay yeah but I you
know I'm happy they're doing well and
I'll say this uh they seem to be doing
really good and their baby is beautiful
and Trish's Trish's been like staying
out of controversy so she's she seems be
doing well all right well that's good
mhm he got some nice thigh highs
there I'll be I haven't told this story
but I'll say
it we ran into them recently oh shut up
I know this is Big T oh we were
doing a
Halloween it was some kind of Halloween
popup event um where it was fun it was
like a little Halloween Carnival that
that we brought the kids to and who do
we run into but um
Trisha Moses and their their lovely
daughter who I had not met before oh wow
and I mean it
was I don't know how they felt I didn't
think it was super awkward I mean we we
we exchanged nice pleasantries and we
moved on WE there was no further kind of
in in there was no beyond that but it
but we ran into him and uh it was
interesting it was very interesting wow
it didn't feel like uh didn't feel
uncomfortable well it kind of so here's
what
happened we were walking with the boys
it was packed yeah and ela's mom was
with us and she's straggling and we're
like what she's talking to someone like
who she doesn't know anyone who's she
talking to and then so I walk back there
with the boys and I go oh oh it's
Moses and Trisha wow so I wasn't going
to be a weirdo and like run off so I
just walked up and said hi how long had
it been since you'd seen
them I don't think I've seen her since
she St Med out of the right w w no
I mean I don't know you tell me same
with Moses I don't think I saw either of
them since they no since we broke up wow
wow man the uh the Tik Tock Clips are
about to go crazy well I'm not sleeping
tonight I got a lot nothing really
listen nothing really happened but I'll
say it was nice to see them I haven't
seen them in a long time they look great
and I'm happy for them that's nice
that's is diplomatic and pleasant and
sweet not even I am I am you know there
there's there's complications people
always wonder like why don't we
reconcile why don't we bring the show
back
and there's complications beyond what
you guys know that's all I'll say about
that but on my end I thought it was it
was nice to see him and uh God bless
them for that and I and I love that
they're growing a beautiful family I
really do as a parent myself
yeah children are the best they're the
best and you know if anything it makes
people more mature it makes them more
responsible it makes them more loving
and empathic individuals or it destroys
them right it destroys everything in
their life shatters their psyche forever
and the child also also the child might
be traumatized for life too and end up
being a serial killer or something but
those but there's two paths that's right
that's it's a or b and there's no in
between I don't believe they're walking
that path just to say for the record no
that's nice that's nice all right that's
nice and wait did there is the cat out
of the bag on the baby's name I saw oh
how long has that been out is she's
always said that she wants to name her
baby Elvis so here's the thing El it's a
girl yeah named Elvis okay Like A Boy
Named Sue yeah that's the thing right El
I mean it's a choice I suppose I mean
L's cute L is cute L's nice that's
nickname L
guys cute yeah that is nice really nice
Elis you know what
right that is cute honestly it's
probably better as a girl's name than a
guy's name because a guy named Elvis
like you're just trying to be Elvis it's
like really bro right she's going to
reclaim Elvis that's true and also
there's so many like there's so many
feminine sort of names already that are
L based elvir and Elizabeth and all it
makes sense in that family right Elvis
God people are losing their minds if
Trisha pis has enough babies we might be
able to end the monarchy
why is this so funny somehow everything
around Trisha always ends up being a
story like she didn't even try to but
like in the world there's this cosmic
alignment where the Royals just die in
perfect Unison with her baby's being
breathed of life and somehow it turns
into this this whole thing 41,000 likes
in two hours like this is Jesus Christ
This Is It King Charles is going to
die unimportant if you I haven't
seen the diagnosis
I don't know anything about it but that
he's toast he's out he's out Buckingham
Palace has announced the death of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth II I'm I'm about
to spread his ass on a toast like a can
of
beans serve it up serve it up baby with
some butter of Charles you know what I'm
saying well done speaking of Elvis did
you see what Trump put out over the
weekend uhoh so true okay hold on sorry
sorry I haven't watched this video and
so I've said so many nice things about
them and I mean all of it but on the
other end this video was so iconic she
was and I mean this with love peace and
love it is funny I think she would admit
she was doing um Medi meditating yeah
and people were throwing Tomatoes at her
on Tik Tok you can pay money to
throw
tomatoes I I mean it's just
bananas I've never seen anything like
but again like without trying it's just
so
iconic what can I say she's she's one of
the great entertainers of our time it's
true it's
true
anyway this yeah so okay that's a huge
event he tweeted that out yes yep I I
checked it myself for so many years
people have been saying that Elvis and I
look alike now this pick has been going
all over the place what you think I
didn't know Trump was on
Instagram he's just is he on
Instagram I guess so yeah that was my
thought as well Trump Trump's IG he
crushes on social media man you know
he's the man I I'll be honest I'm I
think there is I see the resemblance
actually I guess a little I mean it's
not the worst side by side that's true
that's true it's in the lips or
something there's a slight skin tone
difference in skin tone a little bit
eyes skin texture texture generally skin
RZ but all this a little more RZ on the
skin skin voluptuousness
yeah but the look that there it's kind
of like the face tilted downwards okay
yeah cam here's what I need you to do
get end of life Elvis all right and and
let's do the mash up with him Trump
that's the real heroin
Elvis all right sweaty heroin Elvis
that's what we need but anyway welcome
uh welcome and uh farewell to King
Charles and welcome baby Elvis welcome
welcome so do they what do they do do
they open lizz's box and throw him in
there or does he get his own box I think
he they could probably AFF a second box
that's cute though a couple's
box with his mommy mother with your
mommy sure cuz I'm going to cuddle
afterlife sucking at the tee just like
the beginning right okay fair enough
it's a little weird but this is um this
is more accurate in my opinion yeah
merchandising oh wow wait who is this
Yoda ass looking that's yogurt dude
that's Yogurt wait that's for for real
Yoda Space Balls oh Space Balls schutz
be with Trump has the schutz wait Mel
Brooks is still alive isn't he he is
still alive talk about someone who ain't
never going to die is didn't he just
turn a 100 or something dude he not only
is he a century old he just made that
movie 97 yeah he's still working
okay was it good he made history of the
world what was it part two probably
sucked it was part two no sense yeah I
mean it's like an anthology comedy with
a bunch of people who I probably just
signed on to work with him but it looked
kind of crap I mean the guy's got a
quite a accomplished career but I'll say
this about him and he's 97 so don't take
it personally but yeah I've never seen
somebody's skin that looks like
this I mean yeah he's almost 100 years
old yeah and that's what I say it's not
it's not personal kid if you it looks
yeah it's it's a surface of some
plan it's like a geological
event but we love him no absolutely okay
here's a question is
anyone who in their
9s is doing good
work uh I mean you could even ask you
could even take it back who in their 90s
is doing work even better I don't think
period not many not many doing good work
well I don't think he necessarily is
either I haven't seen it though that's
what I'm saying is like is it possible
in your 90s to
do I guess so this one okay this one is
pretty accurate I got to say people have
been saying I look like Adolf
Hitler I don't know what do you guys
think no that is excellent if it's if
anything it just kind of goes to show
that you can face smash pretty much yeah
yeah anything yeah we love them though
it works it works we wish we're all
rooting for him there's a lot of we hope
he does well we really hope he becomes
president Hitler yeah wait is this real
is this this isn't what Elvis actually
it's probably gonna happen right what
he's probably gonna I think go on say it
going to be presid I think Biden's going
to win you think so I do real
there's a lot of time left I think
people are going to start to remember
why they didn't vote for Trump as it
comes closer and closer and I think the
economy is I know that consumer
sentiment is pretty bad yeah very bad
people don't feel good about the economy
that's true despite on paper the economy
doing like uh pretty well you know but I
think shut up from what I understand
consumer confidence is Raising M and all
category all demographics yeah and so I
think by the time the election actually
comes around I think Biden's going to be
looking good I just think we tend to
underestimate this
and like I remember the
first one everyone was like not a
chance yeah not a CH are you
kidding me this is a joke I know it and
then he was the president this guy that
dude I know is this a this is not
Elvis's real physique is
it
yeah dude yes yeah that he got that big
yeah yeah what right I mean I need need
you're asking that's a real photo of
Elvis with Trump's head put on it cuz
he's got like the whole I don't think he
got that Elvis never got that big no his
butt is on his that's what yeah I don't
want to point that out but I mean what
do you call that the I mean it's a FAA
but it's more than a FAA it's like a
fussy it's a supera fopa it's
a
a f a f a f um yeah so that's Trump we
love Trump and we all rooting for oh we
just all so much this is him he doesn't
look that bad I've been fatter than
this oh yeah that's not that's that's
not bad at all that's not bad at all man
I think it's just like he keeps trying
to dress like a WWF wrestler yeah and
it's with the age and the weight it
becomes a harder look to pull off and
and compared to to like how he did look
yeah you know that knee shaking stud I
don't I'm not a fan of Elvis no I think
he oh God people hate me when I say this
I just don't like his music he he's too
sexual for
me I think he's I think he's destroying
the Youth of America destroying the
youth with all this knee slaping
shakeing KN I just I just there's just
so much good music out there and I'm
just not crazy about Elvis I'm with you
I'll back you up on that I don't
actively dislike it but it's it's
whatever the only thing ches a fun song
the thing that puts me off to him is the
whole appropriation thing that is is
valid you know this thing of like
co-opting Chuck Barry and and just
like whatever running with it I know
that's the reason a lot of people don't
like I I don't know enough to speak on
that I don't want to touch that because
people will say that I said something
wrong and then they'll want to kill me
oh right yeah but you you nailed it what
he said it's it's it's it's mostly true
I would say I mean I still think he's he
was a great performer you know I mean
you can give the man his his credit in
that I guess department but yeah the
other really up thing is that
like didn't he like a 13-year-old
his wife was she was like 12 or 14 they
met yeah she was 14 when they when they
married no I think they married when she
was like 16 let me they started dating
when she was 14 now that's a hound dog
baby it's Pages come on over here little
Lassie
you ain't nothing but a hound girl come
on here baby today Elvis was 24 when he
first met Priscilla who was 14 hey
Priscilla when you're done with those
monkey bars come on over here and take a
seat with
Elvis how's recess H okay I guess when
they got married she was 21 Elvis was 32
but they met when she was 14 that is
Mama M so I'm feeling like a
pedophile today like even back even back
then
when was wild that's still pretty
nut that is
unacceptably like I don't think people
are walking around 14year olds
as a matter of business no even back
then I don't think they were yeah come
on here now bab turn off them cartoons
and come sit with your
uncle God Uncle Elvis got something like
to show you there come on
now yeah he's
gross but we love him too at the same
time love him so American Icon just a
criminal 14 pages what he say sex
offender 14 years I played the sound
bite I think that's why they uh they
might have said that oh you did it yeah
go
ahead it's 14 nice 14 years
man uh we have too much fun here don't
we oh
man is a pedophile We have basically not
even gotten to the number one on our we
have nowhere that's surpris um we want
to okay so I saw this post and frankly I
don't know if it's true or not but if it
is then I think it's I'm just going to
think it is because what he's what
they're asking I don't know if it's uh
what's their gender but what they're
asking is something that I think is very
um it's it's good for the show frankly
cheers my dude love you no
homo I was diagnosed with stage four
cancer two weeks to live and I thought
it would be really cool to experience to
remember in the dark abyss of afterlife
to be featured as an honorary H3 sound
bite that they can use for future
reactions to videos and Goofs sound bite
is Mr Beast saying this sucks uh
he gave us where to find it go ahead
Zach this suck just suck where's
the S so okay so here here here's the
problem with it it wasn't super
clean you're dying and that's the one
you sent
us however
um I we we did Dan and I did Doctor it
to this this sucked oh you you
preempted me yes pretty nice you guys
can here's what I would recommend for in
their memory and their honor yeah so
that in the after Afterlife they smile
upon us right and don't curse you Zach
specifically Z it's important I'm
sending nothing but love to you so let
me hear the the remastered this
sucks we can hit I think we should Rec
somebody just going we can oh just to
hit the last I don't even think you'll
notice the problem is that s there's a
laugh that is overlapping with stepped
on yeah oh right at the end yes well cut
it here's what you should do cut it
where so it's not overlap and then say
this sucks and then just take
the end of you saying it pack it on
there I bet you won't even notice okay I
will do that I'm it's so bizar it stage
four cancer two weeks to livep he that's
it he really just rushes by the
diagnosed stage 4 cancer two weeks to
live anyway you know what I mean that's
you know uh I hope it's not true that'd
be great but but if it is true then uh
the family is with you my friend and we
we will honor your requests absolutely
100% please don't haunt Zach he's doing
his best don't I'm I'm sending you
nothing but prayers and love don't haunt
me and wishing you very peaceful loving
last couple weeks yeah man if there's
other soundbits I could play for you
please let me know yeah send them over
we yeah we'll give you a whole we'll
give you a whole playoff but I would
like to see it clipped and used in one
of the future podcasts I have very
little to watch of theirs so if we can
get this super upvoted and noticed by
them it would be complete my life my
short yet well-lived life Papa bless
yall peace and love Olivia hey girl Papa
bless hey girl please be this please be
this the reason you guys remember and
honor me Olivia's hand thing and also my
username is Gorilla team Casino don't do
you think that they would give us their
name I don't I don't want to doubt their
story I love them I'm with them what
would you do with two weeks bro I would
just be that's just what do you do with
that I mean I just go home and be with
my family if I have any energy try to do
fun stuff I don't know but just be with
them the problem is at that late stage
of cancer you probably need like
painkillers and otherwise you're
just it's kind of miserable yeah I mean
I hope it's not true man I hope
you're just goofing but if it is true
we're with you we're with you
absolutely
absolutely and we're we're going to
master that sound
bite yeah I like but just putting a
little s on the end of it let's see how
it works can you do it during the show
Zach uh no I can do it after
though does there anybody do it during
the show maybe cam can do it
you have you do have two weeks to do it
I got
you right give or take give or take
really you know it's it's it's really
not a exact science right that's true um
that's true we don't light of it though
let's see Jay shed you know who this
guy is Jay shett okay I know the
name but give me the nutshell scumbag
charlatan conman Guru oh really phony
baloney
is he like a Lex fredman style like mind
pod well he's so much more than a mind
eyes too he's like less than a God but
more than a
man he's a Dem a Dem as a matter of fact
so here's this and it's
funny there was like a gajillion post um
on the subreddit people saw him why J
Shetty is a podcast host why is
he sitting even in the world where he
gets invited to this event yeah why is
he sitting at at the front with the
Stars like Trevor Noah sitting right
across from I saw another picture he
were sitting next to like
uh I don't know some big ass like A-list
celebrity like Jay Shetty you are not a
A-list celebrity go away bro was
he nominated is that Ben Stiller next to
who is this it looks like some big time
guy but I can't I don't know who it is
it does can we get an ID on this
gentleman Jay shitty yeah he
sucks but you know it's like poop are we
wasn't nominated at the Grammys for like
audio book or something audio book he
would be nominated for that dumb
category here's the thing I see J sh
this man
is so he has a podcast sucks
yeah it's a scam is it like an interview
based thing he talks to people and he
just glazes them up talks to huge people
amazing guest that he on there Michelle
Obama just recently you know who did you
know Lex fredman messaged me like a like
twice in the in the last month he wants
you on the show yeah oh that'd be great
you should do it should I though why not
I don't know I just feel like I get I
get like a Rogan vibes from he he's
Rogan adjacent most definitely but he
doesn't seem super partisan although
I'll say this I saw a tweet re that he
just put out that was absolutely
mindblowing really Tucker is going to
Russia to interview Putin oh God and Lex
Lex tweeted out I think this is great
news we need more convers not less it's
like do we need more Russian propaganda
mainlined into American conservative
movement from Vladimir Putin is this an
honest conversation that we think is
good for the world do we think Tucker
Carlson is going to challenge Vladimir
Putin on any single one of his stances
are they going to circle jerk how about
the West is falling and that like I mean
what the are you talking about we
need more voices out there like did this
was such a colossally bad take that I
was like whoa dude
28,000 what who the if Tucker
interviews Putin that's great we need
more conversations not less we don't
topics dude I'm all about tab sucks with
who smoke crack listen if if I thought
he would conduct a responsible interview
I'd say great I mean people interview
Putin all the time he does interviews
with with you know I've seen those
interviews Klay Thompson and when will
you be interviewing Putin lexs oh
God but
um you think Tucker will ask Putin about
Obama's gay
lover that could actually come up in
that interview it could sick then had
sex with cracking with
me oh yeah people now people are getting
cuz Lex is Russian and they go oh he's a
Russian operative which I think is dumb
I don't think he's dumb I mean maybe
I'll do it Freeman is Russian I didn't
know
that don't know if I want to be a it
just feels like a weird Lane to start
traveling that that just that world of
the of the
Rogan um orbit Galaxy I think he's
probably one of the the better ones to
do oh okay yeah all right I would say
like he's okay there's a few podast like
theovon is good he's not super partisan
and and then the other one is um Shen
Gillis is super funny and not partisan
gotta you okay other than that I can't
really think of many don't want to you
know you want to make a wrong step and
then all of a sudden you're like
associating with yeah bags
yeah I'm such a sucker U he no I think
he's I think he's fine what do you guys
think any thoughts from kind of same his
Edge case I guess okay yeah but I'd be I
don't know I I I've seen him uh conduct
some pretty good interviews with people
uh it's interesting that he wants you on
though like I I I guess he talks about
anything I've just never heard him
really like talk about music or anything
which presumably is what he I'm just
going to respond to him that's cuz he's
a curious mind Dan he's a curious mind
we go ahead and respond to and now my
dear friends I give you Mark
rubier I I think it would be pretty
funny if he'd perform work that ass for
daddy the vi that's kind of more like I
you know someone said someone said
stavos but he's not in Joe Rogan's orbit
I wouldn't I wouldn't put that on him at
all oh really he's doing his own thing
staros uh oh yeah yeah the the Greek
dude yeah dude he came up cuz like when
you're in Joe Rogan's orbit he's popping
he's popping stos is popping and he's
he's such a funny genuine dude and he's
on such a different wavelength than all
those Rogan knites and so many of the
famous Rogan comedians are literally
just famous because of him just pushing
them relentlessly and stavos did not
benefit from any of that he's just
a good funny dude isn't that some culty
though how like that everyone just
like up and like moved to the Austin
like a compound it feels very cult I
mean listen they people uprooted their
families moved to Austin to be
close to Joe Rogan just really I mean
that tells you all you need to know
about that yeah yeah who who think
Butters their bread you know what I mean
yeah Bobby Lee is not in Joe Rogan's
orbit he just did his show for the first
time Bobby Lee is definitely his own
agent of chaos that's for sure yeah we
we we love Bobby we do love Bobby yeah
that's an unusual human being but um
yeah I I think Lex is cool okay I'm
going to say let's do it I saw an
interesting comment though people are
like uh so according to Lex a
conversation with Hitler in the in the
middle of you know World War II where
you just the from the American Nazi
party glazing him up and spreading
misinformation would have been a great
conversation no
no like Putin is an evil warmongering
Tyrant yeah the dude kills
people like every week week yeah who
like looked at him wrong
yeah my dick hard Zar real Zar energy
true you know it's in his blood mhm Zar
it up anyway up dude what I was going to
say about shett is like bro don't you
have to do he's at every
award show I feel like every week I see
his ass at another award show and like
he's not even the Grammys what do you
have to do with that bro like the stream
like this man goes to the gramys and
then a month before he goes to the
streamy like he has no standards he'll
go to any award show like bro give me a
break how desperate are you for
attention man don't you have kids and
listen I know people say that to me all
the time they go oh aren't you spend
with your kids okay this man I don't go
to an award show every other night don't
you want to tuck your kids in and say
good night and kiss them on on the
forehead no his people do that for him
you know he's got little he's got monks
that just take care of his house tuck
his children and give him a glass of
warm milk okay here's the uh mastered
sound bite this suck oh that was
weird this suck that was weird
this suck that was I don't like
that I think the one Dan and I made
sounds better than that I agree yeah I
think you did you do some kind of like
cross fade or something cam uh so in the
initial clip I he he gets cut off with
the when he says sucks so I try to pull
a different s out of it that's what we
did yeah so I gu you this sucks
you got to use your voice man I'm
telling you I I promise I will have it
to you for the next show all right I
will make that granola right here
absolutely help yourself yeah bro what
if he dies before
that Ethan come on dude there's any kind
of people that are that just who like
social life is being at CNB seen parties
you know what I mean yeah that like
I guess this guy is one of those guys
it's just so phunny like dude you really
trying to play You're trying that hard
you go you show up at the streamy like
at least do yourself a favor don't go to
that one if you're invited to the
Grammys don't go to the streams man yeah
give me a break what's next you're going
to be at the like U Academy
Awards for
what hate that guy give me a
break you know what I mean if if I was
going to the Grammys I show up at the
streaming that's embarrassing you don't
do to both those Worlds the problem is
he always goes to the streaming and he
beats me every year for every category
really yeah and it's total it's
absolutely rigged sucks who's to
say he didn't go to the streamy to meet
Ethan Klein well if that's true why did
he blow me off in DMS he did oh in the
DMS but not in person in person he was
very no he was super nice in person he
loved me but then I was like um I was
like hey you want to come on the show
and he's like no
what basically really I mean more polite
he said there was nothing to talk about
it Jesus Christ I'll read it I'll read
it I'll read it too it's good see he's
it says he's an
author yeah yeah I'm a author
yeah yeah I do my doc I I work in the
document every uh day I'm an author what
do you write 15 million followers so I
said hey uh dude he said hey he
messaged me first he said so good to
finally meet you I thought that was so
thoughtful he messaged me that is so
nice very sweet and I said hey dude
congrats on the win he harded it okay
then he said thank you mate you deserve
it that's ingenuous that's not genuine
who's to
say well if he okay then I says Jay
would you ever want to come on the show
and talk things over I'm being silly
because we have like a pseudo beef oh
it's a one-sided beef oh I see yeah okay
it would be super fun I said and then he
responds
he responds two months
later after leaving me on right he says
happy New Year Ethan hope you're well
haha nothing to talk over all
love you dude that's what I'm
saying man that's the most passively
like nah nothing to talk over I sent a
comment from our episode talking about
it that kind of sums it up really
well let me pull that yeah exactly this
is this is exactly what
Ethan said Jay please come on the show
he said no
heart that's so sweet but no thank can't
I guess I'm not big enough for him maybe
when I get a Tony I'm gonna do a song
get a Tony where's your Tony piece
of why and also you wait two months
two months he left me on red what the
is
that that's a good question that a
reminder on his phone actually speaking
of Joe Rogan um oh this my arch nemesis
Kevin I argue with my co-workers every
day that you guys have surpassed stern
oh well that I wouldn't argue that but I
appreciate the nice damn first of all I
appreciate the um the compliment I love
that but I I I've been listening to more
Stern lately creating he's still L do
you believe that yeah he's still making
a show go ahead a I was going to say we
definitely beat him in sound bites I
think for sure I think Zach is I mean I
really yeah I'm I know it's a bold claim
but what kind of sound bites are you
hearing from them I don't know when I I
don't know it just seems a little old
timey for me I just feel like Zach is
like an encyclopedia he's like bumblebee
he just speaks with the sound B it's
honestly Fred used to be a lot better he
slowed down a lot maybe that's and and
when I've listened in the past few years
the soundboard is like absent yeah
really yeah but Zach defin I mean Zach
has surpassed Fred there's no I mean
soundboard just a radio standard but
they're really they took it to another
level other people did not I learned I
will say learned like everything I know
from him just by listening for so many
years um so to his credit but having
said that I I think I could you've
you've transcended you've transcended
you are the evolution well thank you I
appreciate that that's true uh Joel says
Mark and down sound very
similar driving and I can't tell who's
talking I'm so confused should I change
my vocal intonation that's there's
that's not true they sound different to
me yeah I wish I had Mark's voice
I can't s Dan you have dulet tones
you got Timber bro you got tender dulet
tones tamber you have tamber bro I got a
text from somebody that watches the show
and said am I crazy or does this dude
sound uh just like Dan
real what there's a subreddit post about
it too it must be I don't hear it
there's got to be people not hearing it
I don't hear it at all I think there
must be some kind of frequency uh uh
dysfunction going on in some population
I wonder if on the broadcast maybe it's
it's possible with the EQ oh my God I'm
hearing it now Jesus
Christ I don't hear it hi I'm Dan
so before you say anything hey it's me
Mark rier hey D how's everything wait
Mark can you say I have grown up with
Mega Man I have grown up with Mega Man I
have grown up sound yeah they sound like
you as a matter of fact I have grown up
with Mega Man I have grown up with Mega
Man
yeah Mark if you could before you talk
say this is Mark ruer and then say and
then Dan you say this is Dan SW hey this
is Dan here chiming in hey Mark R about
to say the sentence right here all right
everybody get ready this is Mark Rubi
about to say sentence hey Mark climing
in here to say that I have gr up with M
man um speaking of Joe Rogan
yeah uh this guy is really
lost like every time I see him
oh we talking about Joe yeah he gets
more and
more down the crazy train and I'll okay
just the just that just the the Frozen
thumb Mark R here by the way
yeah is his body Ty look at this man
yeah is Def that's deflated balloon
that's trt and Alchemy in action
baby
Alpha
Brain um snort it you the thing is
too like he keeps getting so wrong
publicly but he just doesn't care like
he doesn't care anyway here's a take
from a recent show where he talks about
the I'll just listen okay I'm sad about
but it's also kind of hilarious is how
many people were promoters of the
vaccine and died suddenly it's crazy how
many young people just died on
throw up the disclaimer this is recent
this has just happened it's crazy
this dumbass freak oh my God
it's talking about how people all the
inventors of the co or champions of it
are dead now sleep after they took it
and everybody's like nothing is he here
sudden adult death syndrome yeah just
died suddenly I think it's funny that he
subjects all of his guests to the same
and they feel this I'm sure they
feel this pressure to be like
yeah yeah wow crazy crazy but what Bobby
Lee did his show and actually it was
really refreshing to see because he was
doing this normal stick to Bobby and
he's like can we talk about something
else that's awesome very good awesome we
love Bobby for that go to the died
suddenly Instagram page like holy
there's so many so yeah he's he's
getting his news from a Instagram page
called suddenly died which I'll pull up
here in a second great so many people
like talking about people who are you
know anti- Darwin antivaxers and then
then you're dead sorry you you bought
you bought into the wrong but
that's you know what would you say they
died from Joe like I don't even know
what he's claiming he like they just
died like what do you think I think it
causes heart failure yeah there's no
details context of any kind I just I'm
recalling he had a guest somewhat
recently that was like oh yeah that's
totally wrong you have a higher risk of
dying of a heart what do you call it oh
rare side effect yeah someone called him
out on it and he and he's like no
actually you're have a higher risk of
this heart condition from Co right and
he's still saying this dumb yeah
he's been told a million times he's just
he just does not give a what's his
listenership like these days I mean I
don't know if it's what it was but it's
still monster really he just he just
signed a new deal with spoy for 250
million and part of the deal allows him
to stream on other platforms as well
they lost exclusivity and they're still
paying him 250 mhm no $250 million
and it's not exclusive ah you know if
anyone's the Howard Stern it's him that
was the kind of that Howard was
pulling back in the day yeah he's
definitely but I'll tell you this you
know that Joe Rogan and Howard Stern
don't like each other and I think that's
a fat dub for how we totally sure he he
does not like Jo that's great that's
nice to hear there's actually pretty
interesting lore there him and Jay Leno
they just don't don't like them Jay
Leno's a J Leto go ahead Joe
really want to get cruel that's
Darwinism do you not know they lie by
now do you not are you not aware of the
opioid crisis you not aware of Vio not
aware of the very
25% of all FDA approved drugs that get
pulled it's one out of four he he looks
like a ogre from Lord of the Rings you
know how they
look hidden in the face you not know
they Li fools Lord of the Rings ogre you
fo uh you talking about an orc or a
troll Ethan no it's a ogre
bro you're about to e you're about to
eat your words bro that's an that's a
ogre isn't it I love the is with Harvey
Weinstein yeah
yeah wait is that Ryan Kavanaugh on the
right that's Ryan oh you're right this
is Ryan got it he looks like Harvey
Weinstein this is Harvey Weinstein this
is Ryan Kavanaugh Harve on the left the
left is not Ryan that is not Ryan this
one is Ryan that's on the right
yeah wait are you saying it's a troll
not an ogre let me see oh well well what
what was it in in uh in the book I don't
there were ogres
were didn't they encounter I'm on the
One Ring Wiki right now this is the
second
one of these rabbit holes were going
down today uh ochr were mentioned in the
context of the riddle game between Bilbo
and Golem okay ogres or Canon okay but I
think you're right that I was thinking
of you're thinking of the trolls though
yeah the trolls yeah this kind of yeah
it's okay not that
great what's happening you want to do
something I'm going to take a picture
okay can I do that yeah
dope don't mind
me
what you what you a conspiracy theorist
you fool Darwin's going to do its work
with you imagine what she's thinking
this guest I don't know who she is or
what she does but like what the
this is like a being trapped at
Thanksgiving dinner with your crazy
uncle that's exactly the energy holy
modifying your jeans you
idiot like what are you doing it
absolutely does not modify the jeans oh
my God how are people saying that still
you dude he has lost it yeah
it's modifying the genes what is she I
wish they would trust fer well they do
support Anderson Cooper brought to you
by
fizer what a it also there's that
thing that behavioral thing of when
you're making an insane point and making
like unbroken direct eye contact with
the person that you're making the crazy
statement to you know like fiser of
course you know that like how are you
supposed to react to that I'm sad about
but this is his subreddit which has
become somewhat I wouldn't say it's a
total like snark subreddit but it's like
half snark oh that's fun uh the top
comment is I've never heard anyone ever
say the drop dead thing until
now but so here let's check out the page
where he's uh getting his news from uh
let's see haven't you ever been haven't
you ever been to the died suddenly
Instagram page this has 500 likes you
500 likes from one day ago Johnson
passed away unexpectedly as his Los
Angeles home after cardiac
issues wow 5-year-old man died from
cardiac issues wait why did why does he
link that to co this is the most Boomer
formatting to this giant
Watermark dude it has 70,000 follow Joe
what are you doing online is this the
one he was talking about are we sure I
it's the one he follows oh he follow oh
oh okay well then yeah this is it nice
it's become haven't you seen this
obscure conspiracy sub uh Instagram page
with 70,000 likes it's 500 likes per
post and it's become your family's heart
bro why are you watching this this is
sad and creepy Gerald Green from P from
pacley passed away at the age of 21 from
cancer this poor kid and Joe Rogan's out
here like being like yeah Co the big
Tech big Pharma got him oh wait so this
is cause of death cancer yeah it's not
even about co wait what cardiac issue
it's not even about
Co oh this is cancer heart attack the
memorial page heart
attack what's the
point this is a regular death just John
Bush passed away he uh yep no detail I
mean this is really maob like you have
to be kind of sick in the head to just
like browse this I mean it's
sad um Star Trek Jeffrey dmer Star Gary
Graham passed away doe to Cardiac Arrest
oh no I hadn't heard about that let's
let's see what how is he concluding that
this is covid related even it's actually
not even a conspiracy page it's just
that's what I'm starting to put together
is this isn't a conspiracy page in Joe's
psychosis mind yeah right and I'll tell
you this should be a warning against
alpab Brain trt and Alchemy it's a
deadly combo that in his psychosis
paranoid mind these images are speaking
to him and saying the real reason I died
is from Co right does somebody know is
this Co related the vaccine yeah Mark
Ria here do you think Joe Rogan likes
these posts do you do you think he
Hearts it double tap that's dou cheeky
little double tap hold on that's a good
question I'll find out well this guy
this one see if you can find out this
one doesn't show any likes they just hid
likes oh no here it is 500 let's see oh
please come on Joey come on Joey no he
doesn't like that one he didn't like
that all right let me know if you find
any man make me very happy so I don't
know what to tell these people that
listen to Joe Rogan
anymore yeah get your get your
together you know I I don't know watch
our show I mean it's better it's more
entertaining it has to be it's more
entertaining this Dan here yeah I
agree we've got our thumb on the pulse
of the nation hard-hitting news this is
where we need to be uh this is where be
did you know that bivo cheated on his
girlfriend
that's one of our main stories today
I'll teach you all about it pleas please
do thank you everyone for being here we
love you guys cheats on his girlfriend
can you believe this guy if if Joe
Rogan's The Establishment that call me a
radical communist damn cuz I'm ready to
overthrow this and then instill my
own uh authoritarian government when I'm
in charge te soldja Boy tell him comrade
let's go Dan SW love here no welcoming
you don't do that okay that was Mark
don't be fooled yeah um liver king tried
F fish did you watch this oh God I I
watch that
disgusting I mean I got to say he did
pretty good with it he did I got to say
he lives up to his um this dude is
is this a recent post yeah I think so
48,000 likes one day ago wow King liver
King I mean he I think his posts
are hit and miss you know okay but this
one is really phenomenal but he's a
friend of the show we had him on he he
gave us one of my favorite sound bites
what was it uh how do you milk a
not yeah how you milk an O God look at
his how how you going to milk an out
look at his tits bro the tits are
swinging tits that's not a real body
wait real quick you have to look at the
top comment of this post it it made me
Needle
King that's good that is good
um so here he is we've tried this fish
so many times on the show so people who
watch know uh it's called sum strowman
it's the worst disgusting most V thing
ever oh really and so King goes for it
do you not know about what is is it like
from we have one you want to try
it are you good with nasty food what I
don't think we have one eth yes we do
don't lie I know we do nice try Dan wait
hold on Mark when when do you have to
sing again when's your next show oh come
on for's your next show when it might
lay you out is it a thing where is my
Olia say no don't do it do it guys stop
wait wait hold Sam we have cans right
if I it's a smell thing frankly I've
tried it it just tastes super salty it's
a smell thing oh really Mark do you have
a show tomorrow night I don't okay
you'll be fine then but but but will my
breath smell like it will we have
mouthwash really yeah yeah but here's
the thing just so you know several of us
have eaten Ian ate a whole ass
fish he crushed it for like 500 bucks
your breath will smell like for
like 6 hours really but he will puke I'm
no he no you won't you will be like
burping up an aquarium until the evening
well watch watch King do it okay when
you smell it you won't be able to eat it
don't well get me that one mukbang girl
that like crushed like 10 cans of it so
oh no show him the the off chance when
you do really well with okay I was
talking about this with my girlfriend
yesterday about the mukbang thing and
there's a lot of these super popular
mukbang uh creators that you never see
them
swallow so they say here's what I eat a
day I have three Sausage Egg McMuffins
right they they're eating them they're
eating them they always cut before they
swallow you never see SW they spitting
them out like wine yeah I think so cuz
you talking about these are tiny you
talking about these are like tiny women
tiny hot women who sit in their car and
have like raisin canes with gravy I I
know what you're I know what you're
saying that's worthy of Investigation
for sure there's one popular one that
that my girlfriend watches a lot Sama or
something and she's big she has a
million something Subs on Tik Tok at
followers and uh they're cool mukbangs
but you cannot see her
swallow try and watch her
swallow just saying it's I don't think
it's real that's what she said I don't
know I I was just going to say I think
we have first Mark Ru
sound I was like oh let that one simmer
try to watch to see your swallow good
people just think it's Dan so true all
right watch watch King do it have you
done the spicy chip that's another
challenge we do oh no I haven't are you
good with spicy yeah I'm good with spicy
so then you'll be fine I could do spicy
we've all done it I've done it twice oh
Lena did two of them nobody's ever done
the sum strowman and straight into the
chip you could make you could be a whole
uh maybe the chip will eliminate the the
odor of the fish it probably would I
mean it is very it is very can we do a
can we ask the people at home they'll
they'll probably want to see it okay but
by the way this I'm going to be
totally upfront this sucks it's bad
you do not have to do it by any real bad
dude I mean Lena do you want to get on
the chips strowman I know you're a
competitor not this
one out not this one I can't do the fish
I support you she's a fierce competitor
fish is the pr really that's the problem
all right let's watch this you tell me
what you think okay challenge take a
listen I'm throwing up already holy
and this guy eats like raw testicles
smells so and I tried can't wait to have
some of this string we may have to edit
it if so we might have to cover that up
so the queen doesn't have it oh
be my so string so it's all over
his chest coming up with the bones too
that's Savage dude Ethan remember he
doesn't shower yeah that
covered in the juice and the beard too
eh oh dude I can't do it I can't do that
it's hor Li G my God holy a
liver gig barely
[Laughter]
talk that was good
well so iisy at the end Ian's the only
one that actually crushed the whole fish
most of us just like licked it or take
it took a little nibble or something Ian
did you have a nice vom oh yeah oh you
from that yeah and it was way later too
it lingers no dude yeah don't do it then
that's I don't want I can't I'd like for
you to smell it at least though I you
know what I please the thing is it
stinks the whole room for like the whole
day I mean here it
is it's bulging yeah struming
pressurized it's just fermented uh fish
that or that sounds disgusting it's just
fermented
fish it's just canned fermented fish
yeah it's not a big deal it's totally I
mean it is safe for consumption try SW
guys it
is this is try and watch your
swallow what why do you say it's not
it's like super Mega salted like
well if eat straight like that I don't
know if it is before February
2024 oh well this there's no way
this well we're close it's still good
it's still good oh maybe we should wait
it's expired yeah well it's going to
expire uh this month so we got to crush
it wait does it have a date it just say
February oh no it says febru it just
says February 24
best
bested my dude well Sweden is very Le it
was canned two years
ago okay but I'm vomiting first of all
it's been refrigerated I mean I'll smell
it no it hasn't no should we open it
just for a sniff it's been refrigerated
it's in a can it's fermented and it's
been refrigerated should we rail it's
not expired it's Fe this is the month
that we're in Fe we could just snort the
broth try and watch her swallow how do
you already have that does sound like
danad that sounds like dead wait do it
do it again try and watch her swallow I
hear Mark maybe a little B all right
let's do a poll let's do here you want
to do and this these are not binding so
don't feel obligated okay okay we can do
s strowman and spicy chip yeah and or S
stromman only or spicy chip only or
nothing none I do the I definitely
do the spicy chip okay so then the
question is s strowman and spicy chip
how about smell the sum strowman eat the
spicy chip how about while okay while
you're eating the chip I'll open it oh
yeah that's
cuz the smell is is I mean the smell
horrific we're eating the spicy chip
while man just putting Mark through the
H3 Olympics today the fish the chip and
talking about Trisha
yeah it's true we've done it all this is
going to the only thing is I don't want
to subject the room they'll be fine
don't worry about us okay I know yeah
you should worry about us not worry you
guys I'm sitting right next to him man
we do this for the show we we suffer for
this our art all right what I'm sorry
what is the poll it's stum strowman
should he eat the suum strowman yes or
no frankly yeah yes or no right yes or
no really there was some Hot Chip
options in there I guess he wants to do
do you want to do the chip I'm down to
do the chip okay I'm to do the ship
enough right stop it Dan put up the pole
go ahead and but what is the pole sh
okay sh just just you don't have to eat
it sheesh I have to smell it I'm going
to I'm going to take a little Dr bomb
going I'm gonna take a little eye
dropper and squirt some juice in your
coffee uh should he eat
the I don't know if that's I'll defin oh
yeah I would love a coffee can we get
coffees Lena thank you so much thanks
y'all appreciate you want anything else
I like my coffee dark I I you want a
snack sure I a little snack yeah a
little snacky you want some pretzels
what do we got you want to go look you
can grab yourself if you're hungry okay
we could also order food that happens
pretty frequently do that I'm down pour
the delivery person though I
haven't eaten anything at all you are so
skinny I wanted to ask you how do you
keep your slender figure I'm skinny I
guess I am skinny or I gu I don't mean
that as an insult you're in great shape
well thank you I mean you're thin you're
tight you keep it tight I do keep it
tight that's true I do a body weight I
do oh you exercise a lot okay good for
you no you're jacked bro every other day
I do like a in the apartment body weight
thing that's um I've been doing for like
10 or 15 years so when you say am I
skinny you mean when you think of skinny
you think like no definition just small
I guess yeah you're not skinny that's
not what I meant yeah I mean I'll take
it we love the skinny uh the nose are
actually winning our audience is taking
pity on us for once thank you thank you
bailing us out here well it's closed
it's closed Dan no okay Mark go get a
snack and we'll see um should he eat the
S the SE strowman it's 48% yes now
people you can get your votes in it's
this is a close
one um oh I have a major 49% Dan
here major update big news oh boy oh boy
you must see this immediately oh my
God wait what is this oh this guy goofed
us why did you do
that I kind of think this well okay so
this is that is a kind of a
crazy thing to post my my guy okay so
that's kind of nuts let me say something
about this when I first saw this I went
to their posst history and made an
assessment that I don't have usually if
this was real you'd see him talking
about it other subreddits having other
conversations about it there was nothing
and so my my perception was that this is
probably fake but when I asked Dan what
he thought Dan Dan said this is real
well I want well I did the exact same
process and what led me to conclude I I
God I didn't say completely confidently
first of all and second of all it was
mostly that his or her uh Post history
um wasn't trolly at all it was all just
like normal post but it was like anime
and stuff and I was like uh what that
doesn't mean any no because because
there there was no there was nothing
crazy like just out like hey this crazy
thing has happened to me it was just
like normal posts you know what I mean
this mother you know I I felt
sympathy cuz my oh my god oh no okay
uh I'm seeing everybody voting to
ban here in the chat a lot of chance for
ban ban for sure I just got a text
there's a big leak in my house oh
uh oh oh no that sucks I don't know
how bad it
is so what do you think are we
Banning no you don't we letting it slide
it's fine at least he came out and yeah
that's all right they're apologizing
they're apologizing sorry that that's UN
in my opinion don't don't lie about that
un crazy thing to post um we'll
delete the sound bite then we should put
it in jail never playing that again that
go himself maybe we should time him
out like I feel like that's two weeks at
least oh two weeks for for their
supposed life give him a month yeah
that's a time out you know what give him
two weeks each what how long he said he
had left to live exactly all right you
got it or we or we ban him in 2 weeks
forever so he dies in two
weeks that's funny I'll never remember
to do it though so you know what also
made me skeptical and I don't know how
common this is but I don't think it's
very common to actually get a diagnosis
like you have two weeks to live cuz
cancer usually if it's that advanced
you're like up I fig it's just a
figure of speech kind of what do we got
a mana and a power bar this would have
never got past Jake dittle that's um
let's see Jake dood Jake do was on his
ass okay 14-day ban oops not to
includeing the ban message you know why
you can go yourself Roy I do
appreciate that they came out though and
um let me see the comments I want to
read if people are being tough on him uh
maybe not are they bad well I hadn't
looked but I don't know I just what I'm
curious what the people's think uh top
comment is Jesus Christ bro why would
you make something like that up yeah
that's kind of my sentiment I don't
pretty much sums it up yeah I don't
really get the angle cuz it was
like just ask yeah I don't know I could
set a timer to ban him in two weeks I
kind like the idea of that you know just
well you could suspend it for two weeks
and ban him in two weeks renew okay uh
okay he's on chemotherapy for two weeks
and then kicks the
bucket that's dude Jesus Christ uh
that okay interesting well that's an
interesting
development um
I want to say uh
unfortunately that the the vote has
people have rocked the vote as they say
it's 52% yes on the sir strowman
you pieces of but again you
don't not a binding poll not not binding
really just an audience sentiment really
Dan SW love here do you know what the
you just did no that's Mark Mark
Mark coming back now hey guys love the
love our audience d word love here
you
well if you want uh some
inspiration he's someone that one of
these mukbang girls I was talking about
who just dominates this stuff like she's
not unfazed by it at all in fact I
wouldn't even say that she likes
it look at her she's smiling she's
smacking she's CH I'm going to mute it
cuz that's vile yeah what the
hell stripping them there was another
one one massive it's hard to grasp this
video unless you've smelled it yourself
I feel like yeah well that water looks
like sludge though I know it looks you
nasty disgus eat that
sh Wait there's another one where it's
like a bowl of liquid and she eats it
all and drinks it we watched it somewhat
recently I haven't heard that slurping
is so bad eat
po this is hard to watch
honestly and the other person is poo
pooing oh she drinks the liquid okay
let's go to this oh no best video best
stop stop that don't do that we got to
watch look she spilled all over e you
disgust you freak shame on you drink it
she's not going to do that look at her
face she's not doing eating
it no no
no
oh oh God you are shitty that is bow
it's so sour and nasty and salty oh my
God if we open that and put my new
jacket in the car I'm speechless frankly
a and this one is eating the poop all
over so you know that's that we can
start with the spicy chip we can do
let's move on and then you tell me if
you want cuz I don't want to pressure
you okay I'll put this right here by
that we can look at it I can think about
what I want to do and then bring the
spicy chip and we'll put it right on
topic okay no sound good 53 the camon is
increasing the people are
increasingly
God but you don't have to be nice to our
guests I know you didn't show up to
do I love this Mark here I love our
guest dance word love here stop voting
stop voting not two why do I need two on
the prop I don't want one of these I've
got it you have yeah oh man try and
watch her SW I've never done this I'm
not I'm not excited to do it a third
time frankly oh but it is very hot it's
the spiciest thing I've ever eaten by
far guys this one is Best Buy a year ago
but it's a chip right me good I mean
that expired too yeah wait oh wait I
think there might be newer ones is that
one of the ones from the first
generation this is the one yeah this is
the 2022 challenge it's not the one that
killed someone yeah we had the 2023 one
from it recently really although no they
died they don't know if it was the chip
I don't think it was the chip they on
the suddenly died Instagram page I saw
it Joe Rogan shared it
yeah he said it was from uh vaccine but
I know it's from the chip it's
definitely the chip the Packy chip that
did it all right well let's moving
on oh we got more in the Discord okay
Mark passed oh no you made it to the
the suddenly
died Mark passed away suddenly after
eating the Hot Chip followed by F
fish damn rest in peace rip to the goat
too young man VX we move them too young
that's really the question when were you
vacated last most recent V it's been a
while okay so it wasn't that it's been a
while I see if if you've been
vaccinating the last
yearely that definitely that we don't
even need to check on the science um
gosh we are having too much fun we've
only made it through like I'd say 1% of
our dog here
wow actually I need a pee so that's a
lot of items you well we we have a we
have a big you
know we have a lot of ground to cover we
go live for three and a half hours every
day H real not every day but when we're
live yeah wow but actually my NE the
next topic is one that I really love and
care about is C Cav updates there's new
C Cav updates here's what I'm I'm going
to run the bathroom take a tinkle you
have a
tit and um I'll be right back okay this
guy go have a
TT you should not eat that uh sh
strowman really agree it's you are going
to regret it what about the expired
don't do that you'll never smell
anything like that in your life really I
think about it and
I the poo poo have you ever seen that
seriously yes it's the greatest thing
classic
um what is is that the same clip of the
um why are you gay no it's the same
genre I it's the same family of
I think that guy may come into that
interview at the end of it there is
actually connection but those are
different what in the same like News
Network yeah something like that why are
you
gay oh it's so
good uh why are you gay somebody donated
50 and said they're starting a fund for
friend of the show Mark uh you might
need uh you might need it on your way
back to New York City oh I see so nice
yeah are you going to drive back as well
I think I'm gonna leave the car here
leave the car here I still need a car in
the wait you didn't eat the hot CHP did
you no
oh I breathed in the
protein bar don't eat the F fish yeah
we're struggling with the protein bar
you might want to S clear of that F fish
I might want to hit this chip wash it
down with a chip you know I just want to
say real quick when I started working
here um we were on zoom and I didn't
meet any of our celeb guests in person
and you were the first one I met Mark
and I was super nervous I got to say
there couldn't have been anyone greater
to meet the first time because you came
in and gave me a hug and like it was
just it was great I really I really
appreciate that yeah cuz I was super
nervous and you were so kind so I always
say I couldn't have has for someone else
better I didn't even read that you were
nervous that's that's really sweet dude
I actually had the opposite Mark punched
me in the face for huge dick when he
came in yeah you deserved it you
deserved it I just put you in your place
and then go do my interview you
leveled blid Zach out dude it was
crazy a friendly clock in the head not
like a big deal the no I just lay
you out you've chilled way out since
since then though I mean we're buds now
yeah we're cool we're cool now we're all
coaster didn't you play The Roxy Zach
thank you yes I did Mark how was that
show my dog ah it was unbelievable
really doing it again though no he
coming home we're doing that coming home
we're playing the eox when are you doing
it again August 11th we're doing the
Echoplex
dude coming home there he's coming home
coming home he's coming home to
La after a long absence we're where was
it that you you you went on tour Zach
that's why this was coming home yeah you
on tour the US to San Diego holy
so now he's coming home coming home
baby finally nice the the the homecoming
tour yes Mama I'm coming home did you
have a nice Titi I did thank you 56% by
it's going up that is a sad St series of
events Dan SW loves here if anyone votes
yes on this
poll
I am going to lose it I'm going to lose
it and I'm going to start moderating all
over this place you're going to see me
moderating here
there you might even see me
moderating I'm going to make a phone
call cuz my house is flooding oh I'm
just going to call for a minute yeah go
ahead put like emergency status yeah
it's emergency do you want me to intro
Aiden Ross or anything or no those would
be interesting they can listen Okay well
you're going to do the call here yeah I
thought you were saying step away all
right so um I just have a minute if you
can kind of just bring me up to date
yeah
yeah fine and at some point during the
morning we got the call from our guys
around 11 and they said that the
basement was filling up with water my
brother ran over there and basically
that if you watch that little video
you'll see one of the pipes disconnected
I think either just too much water too
much pressure I don't know but um when
it disconnected the pump spray water all
over the walls of that little room and
it flipped all the breakers off and
turned the sup pumps off oh wow and so
they just started filling with water and
so what's the what's the damage like the
whole basement level is
flooded so the basement level it's weird
I think the the side on like if I'm
going down that little hallway the
basement on the left is like sloped or
lower than the right side so the good
thing is on the right side there's no
water that's good on the left side it's
like one inch over the carpet oh
that's
terrible all right so well we were
talking basically I'm sending my guys
down there we're going to take all the
furniture from the left side we're going
to put it over to the right side we're
going to take the carpet out and we're
going to suck all the water out the good
news
is we didn't mess with the one sump pump
where the pipe burst but we plugged in
the other sup pump into an extension
cord so the other one is working good
and it sucked all the water out good
that is good we're not it's not
continuing to flood so we're gonna have
somebody to fix that other pump wow okay
I mean yeah whatever you need to do you
know and like you like you were saying
we were thinking about replacing the
carpet down there anyway so that's
probably just sealed the deal on
that
yeah I think we should just get it out
it's G to be so water long it's not it's
not going to be Salvage all and um all
the electronics in there were replacing
it SL removing anyway too so hopefully
oh really okay I don't know if did they
get trash the electronics down
there I my brother showed was on
FaceTime with me and literally the water
sprayed all the way up to the ceiling
drench the walls crazy so um I it's a
pretty powerful you know so I think
maybe just over time that and I think
the volume of water that was coming last
night was just a lot yeah it was crazy
um but I mean like I said thank God we
were there because if that had happened
last
night all right thank you so much I
appreciate you guys going and checking
on it and um whatever you need to do you
know I I'm not going to be able to talk
till like 5 but you can text me yeah
okay
oh
River Pond okay sounds good thank you
thank you very much bye yeah saying you
could start an eel pit now damn yo
that's crazy an inch of water an an inch
of water oh
brother okay so there's like in the room
where the pump exploded
there's like some electronics that
probably all ruin what I'm worried about
cuz I have my desk and my computer and
all kinds of other there yeah I'm
wondering if that got Martin did
this that scumbag jeez I love Martin
okay great news
everybody that didn't sound like great
news at all remember T Martin T Martin
yeah remember that dude what's he up to
what's going on with it what's up with T
Martin Love T Martin that name does
sound fam famar what did he do got T
Martin on people are saying I can make
an e pit that's true oh CS L that CS L
kind of
true CS go L Ethan tell them to stop so
you can create a eel pit like nice
little kitty pool you guys want to order
food before I move on to Cav Cav
updates what do you guys want what do
you like I'm very flexible okay any
thoughts gang you're the guest I love
Mexican is there good Mexican around so
much good Mexican around you know what I
just had Damian do you guys ever been
been to Damian it's it's downtown it's
Mexican oh do they deliver here no
definitely not a delivery joint but
really good what' you
eat yeah let's take that
let's get some
Mexican and
chil I'll just take a veggie burrito you
know know what I'm saying I'm out on
I've been trying to avoid eating meat oh
really I eat meat but do I have a coffee
did I get a coffee no do you want one
yes please sure thank you your way
around some
meat I'm part Weir to say
Mark that was Dan um partly because ofth
uh but but mostly because I just
starting to feel so bad for animals oh
really
yeah just like the
it's dude it it's just the thing is like
even stopping though it doesn't matter
because people are going to keep eating
them and like they're going to keep it's
just these
Mass meat factories it's like animals
die it's like so evil it is it is it's
so it's unfathomable like we don't think
about it but in China I was reading they
have like a super complex of pork these
and pig pigs are one of the smartest
mammals there is super smart uh
emotional creatures and they just it's
like 30 floors of a super massive
Walmart type thing of just pigs
being grown and killed and jammed into
tiny cages like I just hate
treating life like a Kam
yeah I you're right I mean you're
absolutely right it's like um I do go
through that like every few years I'll
happen upon I'll go down some like
YouTube rabbit hole and and happen upon
one of those documentaries that are like
you know they like Chronicle factory
farming and it me up and I have a
real like moral
Reckoning yeah and then I don't eat me
for like a few days well the truth is
that the day of Rec like I I'm not even
opposed to
um I guess if it's
like yeah the thing is what I'm opposed
to is just the treatment of them like a
commodity like like a con like when you
see the conveyor belts of chickens how
they put them up there like they're
nothing yeah yeah yeah like it's a piece
of fabric I mean it's evil yeah
it's like Fried Chicken on an
animal level it's it's Mass genocide
like a it's just it's really
unfathomable suffering and pain and just
uh it's so evil there's no good
argument for it I I think and it's just
well you're right it's because it's yeah
you're right is bad in every way it
tastes good that's the argument tastes
really good yeah how are we able to
LeapFrog all that so easily because
it's like I've just love that 10piece
because you're not see cuz you're not
seeing those document every day yeah you
don't see it it is the the alienation
from it the distance they intentionally
do it they're like secret operations out
in the middle of nowhere because it
smells vile it's just a place of
suffering in hell right poor animals
tastes
like there's like organic I don't
organic to me is a giant scam but when
it comes to beef organic actually does
mean something means that the cows were
raised on pasture and uh were fed
natural diets and that they were killed
in a humane way and stuff so so like
there are ways in my opinion thank you
to raise animals in a way that I
find acceptable how interesting but the
way it's done now is just vile like you
can have freerange chickens that they
live like normal good happy lives and
then and then they just walk into a shed
and lights out right they don't even
know what's happening yeah that's not
what that's not what's going on I'm down
with I'm 100% down with I feel like it's
like it is part of the cycle of life
animals do eat each other we are animals
we eat we have incizors that are meant
to tear through muscle and you know so
but it yeah it it's just like you said
it's like the mass commodification it's
so H so depress
yeah and it's yeah so I don't know I
don't I don't know why I've been
thinking about that more than usual but
I just veggie burrito if there's a
veggie option that I like I'll I'll go
for that you're getting on that
existential
grind welcome to the club Z I'm so much
older than you I've I've been on
existential I'm off existential I've had
like three existential Journeys you're
if anyone's new to the game it's you
Brother come on in the water's warm I
welcome you feels good in here yeah how
many an persons are you on because I'm
on like three I haven't gone down that
road yet exactly I'm I'm there though
I'm kid I'm
there not to uh not to uh say anything
about the usage you know you know I
advocate but you don't have to take it
I've been I'll be honest I've been
prescribed um oh that's I'm just I'm
anxious to take the anxiety Med but you
know that's exactly what I went through
right it is yeah I I was prescribed it
and it was in my bedside for like months
and months and I never took it and then
it was the Bill Burr episode
that made me finally start oh which
was actually you know turned out to be
really good for me in that case cuz yeah
cuz it the anti-depressants
have un unbelievably improved my life
really yeah it's crazy to think about
Zach you said you've been prescribed but
haven't taken correct I'm in the same
exact position for like the last four
years I've just had I just refill them
and keep them but really oh my God you
have a whole arsenal of it eh oh yeah
wow so wait what what what kind of meds
do you guys have I got prescribed Zola
okay that's pretty standard what about
you Sam I have uh Prozac and Lexapro so
I'm on Lex Pro and I love I think Lex
Pro is awesome I've never tried any
other anti-depressant though but um oh
oh you do too yeah I used to do Lexa Pro
but I switched like two years ago to WB
and Zoloft I'm on wellb Lexapro hey girl
yeah sisters we love that yeah we do uh
mood stabilizer is that no those are
anti-depressants ssris gotta yeah yo or
well no well is not SSR but get your get
your mind right but let me ask you guys
this what are you scared about I I have
like I've talked I have existential and
I had a a really bad panic attack about
two years ago just just out of nowhere
and it kind of I've I've never had this
but I created performance anxiety for
myself
um so that that's been a big Factor
performance in what regard your penis or
playing yeah what what performance just
like like doing my job or you mean here
on the you mean here at the office well
here at the office but um you know on
stage like when I have a show or before
the the
[Music]
Dolby
I got it guys I got it yeah did we B wor
I got it yeah Dan got it oh good don't
say the name again Mark Mark said the
name of the restaurant so we buttoned it
up it's okay but we have a button oh
amazing we hit the button no no harm
done at all we just erased it memory
hold it that's nice that's nice mhm Mark
rier here coming back from the hole
memory hole baby some said you can't
come back from the memory hole I say
Prov yeah all right so you got the menu
good got that menu um but what are you
scared about Zach in terms of like
starting the medication what scares you
about that that it's going to change me
and might take away some of my
creativity right um because I think what
it is is I want to do the best job
possible like for work like you know I
want to make sure I'm doing a good job
and things of that nature MH um I I
don't know I'm just so I I've talked
about this you know a lot but I'll tell
you
this I think that's a that's how I fear
I was afraid of the same things that's
why I would put it off for so long but
for me it put me in such a better heads
space I'm more creative I'm better I'm
more focused I'm you know functioning in
every regard better yeah and here's the
thing also you can stop taking it yeah I
know I just it's not like that big of a
deal you it's not going to like you stop
taking it yeah I just I don't I just
don't want to become like a zombie
that's my biggest fear well how many
people in here on
anti-depressants one two nobody it's
just us
girl I'm not a zombie no I'm not saying
you are I'm I don't even understand that
where that comes from this whole Zombie
Charge well just being in like a hazy
like super hazy and yeah I don't know
where that comes from that's what I felt
before I started taking anti-depressant
that was exactly my experience I started
in like I think 10th grade was when I
first started Lexapro and I was finally
able to like focus in class it felt like
I wish I started it sooner me too yeah
what you're describing Zach is how I
felt
before um I don't know where this
zombie uh archetype comes from but at
least in my experience I can't speak to
everyone's experience I mean if it's
properly prescribed that
works it works yeah I guess to chime in
with a different perspective in high
school I was overprescribed a lot of uh
anti-depressants oh really and I was
zombified on it so really yeah I I think
it's a constant I had a really bad
psychiatrist at the time so it was a
overmedicated what what kind of stuff
was he giving you I can't remember it
was it was in over 10 years now in high
school but I uh want to talk to a
psychiatrist to get on anti-depressants
again though so that that didn't turn me
away it was just a bad experience at the
time make sure you have a good
psychiatrist we'll start there yeah I
guess don't get your meds from Jimmy Lee
let's I was gonna say Dr Dr Weiner yeah
do let's not let's not get psychiatric
drugs from Dr Weiner but I I stopped
taking them and became my old self again
so that's yeah exactly people think it
doesn't like permanently alter you no
not at all you can stop taking it you
know I was misprescribing
that a sleep thing what is that no it's
like a it's like a very intense
riddlin that yeah and it made me awful
awful I like had no appetite I was super
anxious irritable yeah I've tried I I
hate that drug people love it I hate for
me at least I mean it works for some
people but some people love it yeah some
people love it yeah or or I don't say
mean like like some people genuinely I
mean people do take that stuff
recreationally but that's true people
love it because it seems to really help
them what's your uh uh what's your
hesitance
Sam um I so I have OCD my current theme
is like Health OCD so I'm constantly
convinced that I have something or I
will fully convince myself that I have
something um have you thought about
reaching out to Jake
doitt yeah um but Sor I don't know I go
back and forth with thinking that I need
it and then I don't I'm in like super
specialized therapy for this um so I
feel better with Erp it's like exposure
therapy but then some days I'm like oh
wow my life could be way easier but I
don't know what life is like being
easier that that scares me yeah I would
I would say to you similarly that I know
that actually uh anti-depressants help
with OCD and stuff I mean Tourette's
which I have obviously but again you can
you can just go off it I don't do people
get have this perception that it's like
uh pre- anti-depressant post
anti-depressant but it's not like that
it's really not like that I mean I'm
100% still myself in every way
imaginable I'm just less
irritable and uh basically I'm just less
irritable oh and
stressed sorry I I was just wondering
about the OCD that that it you said it
you have a theme does it like does this
the focus of the OCD change
yeah so once well for me at least my
experience when I have a theme that no
longer bothers me I will pick up a new
one oh so uh I I've been in a therapy
with a company called no CD actually hoe
is a like board M that name rules really
CD yeah no CD that is a great name great
it's really great but um like I'll I'll
go through bouts of having this extreme
health anxiety but then when that no
longer bothers me I'll pick something
else up and
a lot of mine are like bodily like I'll
be like oh my God I have fingers and
then it's like I will not be able to
stop thinking about the fact that I have
fingers
wow my condition was similar what my
problem was like circular thinking I
could not stop thinking and if it was
one thing that was bothering me yeah
like I it could be any stupid thing a
memory something happened to me when I
was like 10 you know what I mean
something so in something that so
doesn't matter I would obsess over like
I couldn't stop thinking about I
couldn't I can help myself and then when
I sometimes I get over that and I find
something else new to obsess over and
the only thing that I'll be again this
is my experience but the only thing that
helped me after suffering for that for
like over a decade was um the
anti-depressant really pulled me really
helped me a lot it did God damn
yeah there you have it
folks we love mental health I also have
a chronic we love the mentally ill yeah
I have a chronic case of ligma so I'm
trying to find that's tough there's no
cure for that sorry about that yeah I I
think I got it from love up yeah
yeah I have it too so well you know oh
well have you have you talked to
Jenna wait who
genocide well love he took a trip to the
sakandi islands oh yeah been many times
been many times you guys been hanging
with Jimmy Lee too
much Zach do you really have ligma you
want to find out are you joking
you are joking aren't you no he has it
I've SE why would you lie about
that dude bro why would you go on the
subreddit and lie about having ligma
yeah you caught me I'm going to make a
sound bite you know TR all right so
anyway we love the uh an we love the
depressed here on this on the a podcast
we without the depressed we'd have no
one watching frankly come on come on so
we love we love them
absolutely I appreciate these talks
though yeah um yeah never heard this
kind of stuff when I was going through
it yeah it was always like I was dealing
with it by myself and it was so scary to
make that decision so this is I think
would have helped me at the time I don't
know
ultimately you got to kind of take a
leap of faith in your own mind I love it
I love it let's get you want some drugs
you're not on no yeah it's love to I
have a ton of lexipro I'll hook you up
that sounds great I just got like a thre
Monon uh P subscript prescription fat
vile bro hook it up I got
you bro let's go you know it was it
helped me so much I'll be honest maybe
it'll make me more
irritable because I'm not very irritable
you know what I mean right maybe it'll
go backwards it'll help you so much yeah
that it will TR it will in on
itself turn you into a monster let's
this Mark rubier off yeah you know when
I started taking it and it started
helping I was like this is crazy like
this should be the street drug people
are out there buying B it in and
people need to be out there buying zolof
and Lexapro and wbin cuz that's the real
that that that's the real drug you
need for real that is good and for
the record you don't it's you don't feel
it at all it's not it's not like a
sensation no it's
totally unfelt and also it's
non-addictive it's totally non-addictive
of all the anti-depressants are whatever
that means that's what my doctor and ask
if Will butan is right for you
right or come or I got you or or Ethan
be happy give you some of his three
month supply got Dr Ethan's on the job
yeah all right speaking of uh depression
let's talk about Ryan Kavanagh
hey
um thank you so you know we've been
having a lot of fun with Ryan he's got
his new failure podcast out which we've
been having a lot of fun with he's been
Pro promoting it on his Instagram which
as you know is super uh well supported
by his fans 28,000 likes wow zero
comments ni uninspired graphic design
congratulations where's the comments
generic kind of graphic scr down maybe
say
congratulations like in the post yeah
I'm trying it's there's no oh oh There
are okay I'm sorry let's see um so he
wrote yeah it's about the post or about
the graphic somewhat he God damn it now
I won't go to the
top my you got it you got this
in my
di I just gave you a ddy that's
not uh he says I ask every fan of the
quote Pro troll who has been sent to
on me been sent to on me and
leave negative comments by the way
please stop uh sending death threats to
me and my ex-wife by the way I deeply
apologize for the TW he said go ahead
play it Z I was probably getting 20 to
30,000 death threats a day a day
what this man claimed he was getting 20
or 30,000 death threats a day it's that
possible it's not not possible we did
the math that's one death threat every
or no it's like 10 was it like it was
like 20 an hour or something yeah 20 no
no no no per minute it was like it was
like 10 a minute or something 10 per
minute
death threats per minute all you're
doing it's every like six seconds or so
his phone's going off another
notification hello hello you I'm G
to kill you oh come on I got a text
I'm G to kill you ohly I got an
envelope I got mail I'm G to
kill you
Jesus yeah he's the best that is rough I
I feel forist a lot of death threat
death threats are not funny and it's not
cool and I always encourage people to NE
not not only don't send death R don't
send them anything don't interact with
him at all okay but this parenthetical
in this caption is is hilarious but I'll
say
this he lost a little credibility with
me when he said 20 to 30,000 death rates
it makes me think that is maybe he's not
getting any death
threats because I was probably getting
20 to 30,000 death threats a day so
let's extrapolate that hold on 30,000
per
day times 365 mathematically per year
we're talking about
okay we're talking about 11 million
death threats per
year at that rate it doesn't work it's
11 million death threats for my boy
hilarious that's like the population of
Sweden yeah yeah every Swedish citizen
hey suck de balls anyway he wrote that
please stop sending death threats to me
and my ex-wife I agree if you're
anyone's doing that uh of the 20 to
30,000 of you stop buy him to him to ask
ask yourself maybe just maybe you've
been misled and should make your own
decision
Ryan
Ryan by the way tune in to my new
podcast any any chance yeah any chance
he's just a sad little troll misleading
people and that he may have misled you
for his own gain my own gain bro you're
suing me you're suing me dummy I have
not sued you at all or well that's
actually not true we filed a counter
claim for the first time just like a
week ago your the you're the pro troll
he I'm the in his words I'm the troll
got it okay I refute that personally
naturally what I'm doing is simply
spreading newsworthy uh information
about a public figure oh okay right yeah
Ian there's nothing wrong with that I
mean I don't see anything wrong with
that um the court cases will eventually
expose him but in the meantime tune in
to my new podcast failure we just hit 12
on Apple
podcast uh new episode drops weekly next
week Bryce Hall and Brad the bull I
can't wait to watch that appreciate all
the support and love I've been receiving
but here's where it gets
interesting he posted this idiot
who's an utter failure in every Regard
in his life the image he posted he says
he's number 12 on iTunes which is not
true and then it says number two
underneath exactly it say number number
it says number number 12 and then down
here it says number
two what happened buddy and he's running
out of bad
that's a
lot yeah what the why would you
post a empty battery even his batter's
failing oh you what time is it by
the way what oh this is this is AI it
must be
right yeah that explains why it's all
crazy look at the hashtag on number
two zoom into number
two anent symbol Ryan what are you doing
man oh man oh wow this is bad you're
such a up wow I mean like dude so
is he claiming number 12 or two I'm
confused I think 12 is the official it's
number 12 okay well I'm trying to verify
that claim right now yeah is well I'd be
embarrassing to prove him a liar I'm
seeing number 76 according to chartable
76 yeah I see that as well
76 guys were number 76 on of how do you
get 12 from that that's insanely um
generous I don't know how he did that
that's got to be I I would assume that
there's something going on behind the
scenes with that one I don't know I
could never make that claim I mean he
might have got a big Surge from us
talking about it maybe if he is charting
it's because of that right but he was
never
12 that's crazy yeah I mean by
comparison we're not on here well he he
won't be on there after a week you know
sharts are notoriously easy to
manipulate I'm not saying he would ever
do that of course but by the way the
only the only charts that mattered Dan
just cuz I have to supplement your claim
are the the survey ones yes those are
the ones we chart on mhm because they
ask real people oh they say what podcast
you've been listening to we are on that
chart oh really we chart hard on that oh
yeah Edison I mean the viewership
dude they give I viewership is
nuts on this thing oh thank you holy
than you I appreciate it who's
watching what is the I mean obviously
the obviously great tent great tent but
what else it's a small tent some people
have said it's a small tent is it I wish
it was a bigger tent but the people that
are here are it's relative it's relative
you know I mean go ahead but what but
any tips for the people out there is it
consistency is it the membership thing
what's the how you um is crazy I've
been in the game for so long
you I don't know maybe it's a shitty
question it's not I'm just trying to
think how to answer it and also like
this has been a work in progress for a
long time you know we've been doing this
podcast for what like six years five six
years yeah that's true and so and so
part of what's been good for me is
finding the people and the format that
works for
me and these guys help me so much it
makes it
sustainable in a way that it was never
before and and even now we have we're
doing three episodes a week we were
doing four for a long time wow not
including my members one yeah that these
because of this amazing team we're able
to it's the team frankly it's the team I
got a great team let do that's how done
sh out that's how it's done and and also
just to steal Ryan's uh Thunder a little
bit it's also about embracing failure
right because every because for so long
I would end the show and be like that
was horrible I hated it I suck this is
the worst thing ever and but I come back
next week and you know we just work
through it and and uh I feel like I
don't know it's almost like magic how it
all came together and this guy
it's cool man but it's the team I give
them all the credit frankly yeah thank
you guys thanks
guys here thank every thank you thank
you everyone you had a little something
to do with it too be fair um and don't
use AI for your thumbnails we don't use
AI for our thumbnail we we use a a human
AI a a cat what do you call this in Dune
uh Menat we got our own Menat name cam
Grant I'm smoking on that spice pack boy
that's what I'm saying that my an
depress is that spice Milan let it flow
baby yeah
baby Cameron is doing a fantastic job I
think he's a star but to be honest
everybody's gotten continually better at
your their job and um that's really
everyone's just really amazing it feels
like a well-oiled machine it is frankly
it has become that way um it has become
that way yeah it's
crazy great job everyone proud of you
guys proud of all you guys proud of you
guys proud of you proud of you guys
thanks and I'm proud of you guys at home
I'm proud of you guys Al not idiot that
lied about having cancer but everybody
else I feel a surge of
Pride try not to cry I'm trying not to
cry right now cute emotional moments
that will melt your heart you guys fault
it's not your fault it's not your fault
all this year I want no it's not your
fault it your fault thank you it is your
fault it's my fault it's my fault all
right hell so Ryan is a numnuts
loser who uses AI I mean what are
you doing man and then if you guys want
to know the weirdest part of this
look at the comment he left was it on
this post yeah you want to know what a
weirdo freak this dude is look at this
comment on his own post he said please
drink responsibly
what and he he's had a lot of run-ins
without being of alcohol oh really yeah
so he has a I think has a problem based
on his his criminal record his criminal
record uh his complexion the way he
carries himself yeah yeah the way he
conducts himself also and also he said
he wanted to sleep with a 14-year-old
Natalie Portman and then he said too
much wine sorry an inappropriate
relationship with a 14-year-old Natalie
Portman yeah that's rough the she this
too much want Sor hold on that's Elvis
Elvis that's some Elvis he
must love Elvis he's a big Elvis guy
inappropriate relationship with a
14-year-old Natalie Port so what do you
guys make of this though please drink
responsibly I I thought it was funny
Olivia said it's just a reminder to
himself exactly how it feels to be he
put it in the wrong he was supposed to
be in his Notes
app being nice to Future Ryan please
drink responsibly assuming it's not a a
reminder to himself what is it um
um is he just trying to be like
uh like clever somehow with promoting
the
podcast like the his podcast is is so in
depth it's like a social media person
told him you should you should engage
with your own
post did we make a comment yeah did we
did we joke that he looked drunk in the
interview could it be a reference to
that we usually I mean I always assume
he's he's drunk on yeah I mean we don't
know for sure but he sure seems drunk to
I mean it would explain his behavior I
like to go to bed 14-year-old natal yeah
if he's sober then then you should be
more concerned about your behavior yeah
right you know I think it's better if
you're drunk all the time I think he
looks like Harvey Weinstein uh yeah wow
so this guy pardon me pardon my lack of
the lore here but he the he had the the
gambling site
not g no triller triller his big project
well so he was the CEO and I guess
founder of Relativity media back in the
day was a huge production house so he
was a big time producer okay but as with
everything in his life he he failed
bankrupted it and became disgraced I see
now because he has a ton of money still
because life is just uh like that yeah
um he started a venture capitalist thing
I think called proximity media that owns
like half of triller and he was on the
board and super involved with it in the
beginning apparently he's not no longer
on the board I don't think there's going
to be a board there for very long I mean
this place is he became slightly
disgraced I suppose but his first uh his
first guest was this guy
Nigel uh litho litho who was just
accused of like really heinous essay
really including by Paula Abdul what
who's suing him no way yeah he was a
judge on uh So You Think You Can Dance
right oh Jud a bunch of shows yeah he's
like in with Simon cow and like all like
American Idol and all that kind of stuff
so that was first oh boy oh boy one
actually one correction I want to make
because accuracy uh is something that we
do take seriously is that
um we were guess we never claimed we
were guessing frankly when it was
recorded if these accusations had come
out already or not and um we had
concluded that it must have because in
the
interview uh he
says I was removed from my own company
they outed me from my own company so
he's referring to the
Scandal how
however according to well this is a post
from November so not according to this
is November 1st apparently that they
filmed this Jesus which kind of I'm
confused by that because what so it was
it was like a month and a half two
months before this well I think I think
this was brewing behind the scenes and
they knew it was coming and so he's he
knew it was coming and was referencing
the fact that at least internally he
probably was put on ice because they
knew these accusations were about to
become public right so it is possible
Ryan didn't know although they're really
close friends and the way he moved on
real fast makes me think that that
knew in fact he go there's
one point where he goes Nigel goes I
tried to uh un alive myself and I woke
up in the hospital and there was a
beautiful nurse with her tits in my face
and I thought boy I'm glad to be alive
and then Ryan goes there's the Nigel I
know oh my God oh my God really not
helping his kids yeah I mean dude
everything he touches turns to it's
pretty failure is a great name for for
the podcast he's got the M what's the
opposite of the Midas touch like the um
uh the turd touch what's like a
monster yeah there's got to be a name
for that yeah the Cavanaugh touch just
call it that caban
touch fat the fatur touch what is the
fatur touch yeah
fatb that's good but also the article
that came out from variety I think it
was on the 30th of January he mentions
that Nigel's going through that but he
thinks he'll come out on the but on the
better end of it whoops for sure for
sure he's probably going to jail I think
sounds like I think it I don't think
it's criminal how is it not criminal I
think he's cuz
he I think he's being sued by Paul Abdul
and civil court they might go after him
cuz there's no statute limitation on
sexual crimes wonder what that's true I
guess that's up to the prosecutor he's
Rich he's very rich oh he is yeah pay
out a nice handsome settlement he's
probably worth a lot of money yeah but
you know Paul Abdul she's good too I
feel like she she she won't be one to
settle for a settlement she's definitely
not doing it for the money right right
sounds like he did really up
get paa get that son of a yeah
let's go so
um he actually updated the title I'm
assuming in response to our coverage
because I mean we're the only people
actually watching this and talking about
it so yeah he's updated it failure it's
still one 101 we're confused about this
is the first episode he has his own
methods episode was recorded on November
1st he wrote now in big letters yeah and
so funny that he put a giant disclaimer
and he spaced out the one and the one
one because before it was all together
oh like that doesn't help I'm still that
doesn't help it's still yeah it's still
failure one
101 what are you talking about Bud he
also uh he updated on YouTube too right
yeah the
description yeah he's a good guy we're
rooting for him great guy great guy
great podcast here is the uh here's it
let's see what he changed here oh yeah
no he did add it to the title November
one
when since when since when do you add
the date to your podcast title he is
racking up the views on this well it had
like how much did it have before us like
it had like a thousand or something wow
or was it even that much it was I don't
think it was that much it had a couple I
thought because it got posted to our
right it had some but maybe it was even
lower this is the Talk of the Town this
is what this is what I don't understand
about Ryan the I didn't even
notice holy only 38 people like
that Ryan wait is there a plugin now
that you can see the dislike yeah yeah
it's a add-on on the browser to add it
back oh I love that now I'm going to
dislike it and I'll tell you why it's
not because I hate it it's not because I
hate Ryan or anything like that I'm only
I'm saying this to tell them that there
are certain aspects of this that could
be improved and and I come from a a fan
of the show that wants to see it succeed
so I will be disliking it it's like a
constructive it's a constructive dislike
right I should probably just do that too
just to constructive just as a piece of
constructive feedback is probably what
I'll do the top comment is maybe don't
have someone accused of horrible essay
as your first guest
yeah it's good constructive criticism
but I guess but yeah so to to uh I guess
again we were just guest doing guest
work the first time but now we know this
was filmed November 1 so it's it's very
possible that Ryan did not know I love
the second comment is about as
charismatic as a bag of
milk and you know what's funny I don't
know which person he's talking about CU
awesome it's definitely Ryan ran for
sure cuz Nigel actually was a lot more
even Nigel found him annoying yeah Nigel
was so over it was awesome we watched
the whole thing I can get back into it
again but I look forward to the second
episode I really do Harvey want a
podcast oh no that's Ryan Kavanaugh oh
that who has this podcast yeah Harvey's
in jail got it got it got it can you a
podcast from jail I don't know probably
not probably not be interesting why not
I mean why can't I start a podcast from
jail someone in wuen Clan didn't they
make a song from jail yeah but that was
like small they it was old dirty and he
like recorded it on like an old school
tape deck and then I think it was
smuggled out after the fact harder than
just man like a giant tape deck getting
that into prison not a giant it was like
one oh like a Walkman okay it's the
audio's dog it's remember
Martinelli buying that album
yeah he still owns it I think he still
has it
yeah not the right person to own that
only a million bucks I feel like there
wasn't there wasn't a wuang fan out
there
with more money than Martin scarelli bad
customer bad person to saw that too yeah
I feel also the wuang made an album and
it's only worth a million dollars yeah
cuz there's like 12 members I don't know
how there's a lot of people in that yeah
the payouts kind of relatively speaking
after taxes cut you cut half yeah you
know there's a lot of mouths to feed on
the wuang clan that's true it's a clan
it's a whole clan entire Clan they say
we ain't nothing to with because
they're protecting their rations their
wheat Towers
yeah they need they need food someone
help all right thank you Ryan we love
you thanks Ryan you really do great
podcast when does the second one come
out do we have a release date on it it
just said this week oh I sir remind me
to tune
in to failure with funny it is funny all
right so moving on to the Aden Ross
scheme or you know what would be even
more fun I like the bivo drama I'm not
going to lie bivo cheated on his
girlfriend you guys and I this is a
character that I've been um a fan of he
became famous for not chewing his his
food really and he's become a kind of a
cultural phenomenon like is he a Tik
tocker yeah he he looks like he's about
to die every time he swallows food it's
quite
interesting okay let's see I don't know
if this is one of the good ones but here
he is with his girlfriend sney cooked
and one of the things I actually liked
about bivo is that he seemed like a
family man like he had this nice
girlfriend they seemed really sweet and
in a good relationship and now I feel
like I had the rug pulled can I just say
immediately I know this guy's cheating
on his girlfriend really immediately we
see I didn't get that Vibe he seems
wholesome his teeth are white as
turn the contrast down on those teeth
brother it's got nice it's
nice so um here they are eating
spaghetti have another and uh this video
for the
record oh also who eats it with has uh
500,000 likes so oh God it's going to
who eats it with a spoon because I know
some people do and I asked him and he so
this is the let me show you uh one of
his the teeth really are concerning let
me show you one of his um
famous uh eating videos uh just to give
context to those who are not up to date
on the bivo yeah bivo world something
guys this is is apology I'll get to that
oh boy yeah's out here apologizing oh
man where's the potato one is this we
love an apology this one's pretty funny
too Hey listen dinner Ed Matthew's bivo
I'm treating him to a chip shop Saturday
Sav chips you know the rules big up yeah
this guy's like a famous uh fighter from
England and he's a fan of bivo so they
just met up to really
yeah first time what we trying this year
England bro we love the English but what
kind of plate of food
like only the English would serve a
plain dry ass looking hot
dog like that is not a meal my friends
what is happening here are you a child
are you eating are you all 5 years old
and what the we got ourselves a
right supper we got ourselves here a
spicy dog mate they always start some
silly a dog and a blunder dog in a
flappy a flappy doggy mate
yeah
anyway here he goes CH looks you know
what we should call those King uh
Charles
fingers so watch him
chew down and then he like CHS I've got
the ketchup big up the ketchup you know
the rules me up big up big up the
ketchup over I'm teaching him well I
don't like I would not let another
person catch up my food for the record
look at these sausages
there you go I'm surprised he's still
alive this long I know his ring is about
to explode wait those are his
real fingers yeah he has a medical
condition I see what is it elephantitis
royalty yeah true Generations have been
bre Big Ups hot dog big up to the
queen anyway this is bivo he really is a
legend I'm still cheering he's still
cheering he's
slacking I about a flappy dog in a m in
a stroller
mate down the
Hat bang you know anchoring chips I've
never that's it he swallowed yeah I I've
never seen him do a video where the
person's openly laughing at him so this
is a different type
of got the one punch bag one punch bag
sck one each yeah what you wrate the sub
free what the are they eating what
the hell is coming out of this plastic
bag mozzarella sticks no don't serve
that in a plastic bag it can't be it
looks like it I think it's a crunchy bua
yeah dude Big
Country ketchup big ketchup e oh in one
M let's
see oh he's chewing a lot
that get it down the way he puts his
head down that cuz you ever choked on
your food and you're like
who every
time that's
mine his
whole what are you doing what are you
doing that's stast seven out of 10 chips
his whole look is Iconic chip from the
like the super white veneers to the
badass part oh my God that one was like
no chewing
you a chip man do you go chip sh
frequently you go a lot or no I know
you're a healthy Donnie with the boxing
and that so yeah but I've just lost been
eating that's a big
mouth I'm telling you he's a talent he's
a
talent and I'm I'm pretty sure this is
just how he eats this isn't like a
stick
overall entire fries sitting in his
esophagus right now and he always go oh
that tastes great I
like cheers yeah list he did a bunch of
videos with this guy but anyway that's
bivo just to bring you up to date
fascinating piece of human behavior so
here I showed you a video of them
happily eating together as a couple yeah
here however is trouble in Paradise in
the beginning of January there's
actually a video of them fighting now I
have not seen this but let's see do they
fight fair does one of them
getting dirtier than the other let's
take a look I'm number cuz I didn't your
number I was on live with it happen are
you actually okay okay she did not just
speak the same language as
me what the did she just say let me
go
back you guys need to unlearn this crazy
accent number cuz I I didn't leave your
number I was on live when it happened
are you actually okay
bro I I I didn't leak her number I went
live when it happened are you bro are
you actually okay is that it pretty much
what I got I think she was like I didn't
leak your number right yeah yeah thank
you yeah we can interpret
for get last
I'm you say I'm making a flight I'm done
I want to make the situation i' got love
to go away no you don't you have
no respect for me you don't have no
respect people that have respect don't
do the things you've done
people that have respect don't do the
things you've done you know what you've
done I will bring up
oh they paed probably good idea man
there
ask I'm not say you haven't but you
still kiss three different girls and
it's all over the Internet you all over
the internet right I'm done you going
downstairs you're done did the words
come out my
mouth wait what was that one what the
words come out my
mouth the English are so funny like in
America I feel like there's a perception
of the English as like cultured
sophisticated aristocratic yes but the
majority of people in UK are doing chip
I had a chip in a l doing this
is them this is the
English you know this is them getting
drunk and having and getting in fights
every night oh man this is the
English man so remember this the next
time you hear an English or european
person and laughing at and on
Americans I was like really have you
seen bivo and his girlfriend
fight have you been to a pub on a
Thursday
evening no you haven't we love the
English though we love them we love them
where do they live I want to guess
Manchester that sounds good that's what
I want to guess mhm
Manchester I'm no expert I want to I
think that this is just a like a
workingclass London accent oh yeah I
think so can they to live in British
people will probably yell at me for
being totally wrong about that I wonder
neighborhood in the UK has its own
accent so yeah it's probably I feel
giving London for I feel like it's a
London accent oh you have a cheeky
Willie on beans
mate you have the Queen's you have the
Queen's Fanny on beans mate dude it's
like he has to move his head through the
air so that the food moves yeah back in
scoop it's a fast it's the acceleration
force
though get it back you I've got my own
ke huh I've got my own key well it's
going to uncharge your phone I've got my
own
[Music]
ke oh Jesus Does anyone understand what
they're fighting
about the caption on the Tik Tok says
she's mad that he coughed on her food by
accident um that's the the closest lead
my kids do that to me every
day if you're together you can cough on
someone's food for sure
yeah that's what that's the fight is
over what in oh yeah Sydney and bivo
arguing because bivo coughed on her food
by
accident that's a that's a new one oh
off I got my own
key for coughing on
theck dude my kids cough in my
mouth so gnarly holy got their own
CH if they're sick I am sick there's no
there's no question there's no
doubt girl you better you better chill
in the coughing I don't want to hear you
cough ever
again oh no so this is good stuff oh man
so this is what's going on this is
Sydney those injections are rocking yeah
and like I was on team Sydney even
beforehand but knowing the context I'm
doubly team Sydney she's way too good
for this Beaver
[Music]
character you know what's funny he's
called bivo and also he has got Beaver
tooth he can build a damn with
those
[Music]
tooth thank
you she said you kissed three different
guy girls wait she said that yeah yeah
on cam camera yeah
o well so here this is a for context
this is a video of synthony bivo and
Cheyenne that's Sydney's friend who this
drama is about they're all hanging out
together the day before Oh so this is
setting the stage for a Shakespearean
drama that will rock the world and when
Shakespeare when Shakespeare thought of
the future of English civilization this
is exactly what he what he was picturing
yeah bivo thei
a new Shakespearean play beo boo
beoo so here they all are together this
is the girl in question oh no here they
are before tragedy right teth man the
yeah they have like an ALB albino effect
you know what that is we talked about
that before they reflect Sun back into
space they actually cool the
[Music]
Earth they're so white yeah okay so
that's her that this is his girlfriend
and that's the mystery girl her friend
that's her friend that's her friend
that's how beo knows her Cheyenne is her
friend's name oh no now while bivo was
on live stream Saturday night he was
getting a little bit
touchy with his girlfriend's friend
Cheyenne really here it is it's all
happening on Tik Tok live it's on
live now let me my God bees where's the
audio muted it's muted cuz there's oh no
but the the dialogue is really important
really
yeah
well
sir she's not a hot dog because she says
somebody can you unmute it just for that
part somebody said um your your
girlfriend's not going to like it and he
responded so they're aware oh
really see her she's she's also like mad
flirting she wants that be Evo clout bro
she wants those she wants to suck on
those teeth that's
right I'll clean your gentes tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
baby um they are looking I guess listen
for maybe here oh yeah here here here
here here go ahead syy be fine guys she
saidy will be fine syney will be finey
be fine guys yeah oh oh so that's really
bad that is some I that's some poop
energy that's that's this is enough for
I'm like okay he's cheating game over
that's GG for old
be uh no more Beaver for
Beaver is what she said um but let's see
so then what happen so this brief this
is a brief moment caught by a viewer at
the end of B's live stream where Sydney
finds them flirting oh this
live streamed himself
cheating with her
friend look at this face man
how how this is the face of culture and
Enlightenment refinement what a white
supremacists they say that um England is
the Cradle of
whiteness and I see what they mean
looking at bivo I see the the
superiority of the white race I see it
Sydney finds bivo and shy oh God wait
how do you know that's what happened I
mean his face certainly the end of his
live
stream look at that
face wait wait so bro he is he knows
explain this video what is the point
another another viewer was screen
recording and apparently Sydney because
they were live streaming while he was
cheating on her oh she found him in real
life yeah yeah yeah this is him spotting
her and him being like Oh at the end of
that stream this is the same stream the
same later she showed up she rolled up
stream sniped by his girlfriend man he
is wearing a necklace it's worth
mentioning that says
[Music]
bivo just for the record let the record
show this is this is a face like oh
Bo oh man he is in big trouble that is
that oh man oh so that's so here he is
getting busted app you are done my man
you are done bivo is now begging uh his
e ex-girlfriend Sydney for forgiveness
on Tik Tok pack it up Bo there's one
before that oh okay perfect Sydney
updates for followers on what went down
the previous night okay this is
important this is the best it's all Tik
Tok drama like this is my favorite so
petty like we have Theo guy it's so good
because I was really involved with bbo
even before this happened wow yeah yeah
you were a big bbo head I'm yeah I think
you were the first one who sent me one
of his videos yeah bro thank you for the
respect of saying that talk about what
happened last night with SH B obviously
I'm sure you will seen it um I'll will
add a clip in here if you
[Music]
haven't boy she got receips
oh to listen her friend and her
boyfriend that's
sucks those get very close um flirting
or live don't really understand it but
obviously should have known the girls
been around the app more times than God
knows what but it's just a bit mad like
I've known a girl six
years like she knew I was with b duh how
could she know but yeah they both still
decided to do what they did um I don't
know whether he thought oh I forgave him
once let me do it again and she'll
forgive me not quite sure what his fault
process was during
this um I don't think there's a lot
going on in his mind there uh not a ton
sweetheart not a ton if I can say that
without say he was a thinker yeah yeah
no a deep thinker I think so yeah he's
busy forcing chunks of food down we know
that she can't take keep R that's take
strategizing people laugh but only a
high iqed individual could slam food I
can't do does yeah takes
certain strategies it
does that we've all know who she's been
with who she's been around the amount of
man she's had run through her oh no it
just says a lot about B really she just
call her a hoe yeah big timea out big
time claws her out honestly whatever she
has to say about her get it out AG
friends do not betray friends like that
she is not a girl's girl that's that's a
big that's a huge no like the biggest no
like she's being nice about it
frankly you know up to that point yeah
you know who's not later on you'll see
Cheyenne is not being nice oh really
Cheyenne shame on you this is Tik tok's
version of Scandal right here true this
is a big deal I was about to say I think
I feel like Jerry Springer died at the
perfect moment so that this is like we
don't need someone hosting anymore yeah
you know what I mean this is it so true
the people have the camera now we don't
need you anymore we don't need you he
set it up so that we can knock it down
and I I've said this recently but now
we're just waiting for Murray to die too
so that the world can he oh may it be
what did you say the other week a gentle
passing a gentle yeah it's not wishing
death on him but you know what's going
to come a happy and a gentle past find
out he was really old too yeah no he he
doesn't have long way up there 85 yeah
he do have older than King a gentle
passing yeah oh that's all you could
hope for I hope for a gentle passing for
myself and everybody I do too yeah I do
too just slip away absolutely with your
loved ones by your side yeah holding
someone's hand with the maternity
results in hand to your grandson as they
hold your hand grandson I am not the
father and with he he went out the same
way he came in
with a negative DNA t i I just can't
believe it the fact that they both do
that like be act like oh like I love you
blah blah blah says the most does the
most but then goes and does this the
first opportunity he gets with my well
someone who I dog credit too in the lap
we love we love points there she I love
this girl seems great she seems super
nice I like her from the
beginning but yeah they're both just
snakes to I said something about it I'm
on the record with that okay yeah yeah I
ride for her bro okay good what's her
name again Sydney Sydney no it wasn't Sy
Sydney xox syney yeah with a c Sydney a
c oh yeah know Sydney only a real fan
would know that Sydney xox true true
true
but that's it be is out what else is
there to say well I very that happened
that was up and like first of all
to cheat on your best friend or I don't
know if it's a best friend but a friend
and then to do it on a live like crazy
unacceptable unacceptable crazy so here
now is bivo begging Sydney for
forgiveness on Tik Tok thanks for
putting that out for the people brother
I appreciate that
yep big UPS what's happening guys this
is I am Big Ups to the apology Big Ups
to
Sydney you know the rules all right no
cheating my cheat ones yeah Big Ups to
me follow up what happened yesterday I
know a lot of shit's going down on the
fyp
fyp never heard that on the
fyp I feel like FY saying fyp is longer
than saying for you page
fyp F I don't know fyp sounds pretty
cool though that's the best catch you on
the nyp
fyp that's good shyenne um yeah we was
all out we was all having a good time we
went on live Cheyenne got a bit bit
flirty and we oh Cheyenne got a bit
flirty the really interesting hold on
bivo really dude let me pull up that
video again you pig dog bivo you
dog but she was very flirty with them
but like dude this was was a this was a
Tango
yep you look at
that you initiated brother you know
touch touch another girl like that come
on now she's pushing it she admitted to
being flirty as well well yeah okay at
least somebody admit it
yeah get real real bivo bivo you got to
take some responsibility here King if
you want if you want Sydney to
forgive you it starts with
being
honest and Sydney I think you've just
taken this out the whole proportion you
know what taking it out
oftion victim blaming I thought you were
above that my man is as fake as his
teeth true come on now I've been making
fun of his teeth a lot but I'll say this
because AB made a joke he has a
condition AB oh well you know he's also
a cheater no I'm kidding
should I button that was it
funny it was funny people say I'm too
mean to AB I didn't mean that in a me I
mean that in loveing in that way in that
way thought the comment was funny that
you made I honor you yeah thank you big
up I'll just I'll just keep my
mouth shut no I'm kidding Big Ups to the
jokes we love AB Big Ups to the jokes
and the F the fyp UPS to the fyp huge up
and popping off recently
and got a bit bit flirty and we was just
messing about and Sydney I think you've
just taken this out the whole proportion
you know I've done nothing wrong like
your pal we all know she's a local bike
do you know what I mean so
serious what the bro bro you don't
get to come out and call her a hoe like
no no no kidding
me bivo just really exposed himself this
guy sucks yeah I thought he was just
like a lovable happy potato
eating weirdo potato guzzling weirdo
yeah but he's actually worse lovable
Beaver yeah I don't understand what I've
done wrong I do really apologize I
apologize a lot say I don't want to just
Chuck everything down the drain what
we've had I don't want to Chuck
everything down like a beaver Chucks
wood down I'm not a beaver I do not like
to dark wood I'd like to clear up the
confusion not a beaver not a beaver I'd
like to tear down the the dams i' build
them I'm an anti
Beaver Dent dams te down the dental dams
right we've done um I blame Cheyenne
personally um so I feel like I've done
nothing wrong but I was just there
having a good time just vibing yeah just
VI you got M sted off we went live and
she was touching touching which I didn't
like I'll be real as well look like you
were miserable oh you liar if you didn't
like it you for sure wouldn't put both
your arms around her and some kind of
dirty Embrace yeah you probably wouldn't
be sitting if if someone was flirting
with me that I didn't like the attention
I'd be like gone I'd be like up and gone
right you know
gymnastic mental gymnastics going on
here um but I was pissed so I'm not
going to blame the drink cuz I
understand it is what it is in it but in
it yeah I do apologize Sydney um I know
you're not chatting to me I was just on
live with you and you still bro you you
the apology is not doing anything cuz
you're not you're saying you didn't do
anything wrong so what are you
apologizing for right come on I did
nothing I did nothing apologize though
bollock it's bollock in it anyone have a
piece of
wood God I wish I could do an English
accent it's not fair I don't know if I'm
doing it well it's good enough good
enough that like you shouldn't be
embarrassed to do it like me like when I
try to do it everybody just stops and
stares really we tried to get you
trained once but it was such a disaster
holy we had a spe a coach uh accent
coach come and give me a lesson on air
really and I think we ruined his
life yeah he had like an existential
crisis my dad was the same way my dad's
extremely French and for one of his jobs
they brought a speech therapist in and
he and the speech therapist quit that's
awesome love that it's okay want me on
the live so yeah um but big up big up
supporting
me big up to my girlfriend big up to
everyone big up to this
misunderstanding big up bum
clad if you do watch this I do want to
take you out for dinner oh come on you
I'll make it up to you but just
please message me or something and uh
yeah I'll chat you soon but yeah Big up
everyone support me cheese you not the
don't do that dude anyway baby I need
you I'm I'm nothing without you
she big up big
up he's in cany island where is that
canvi island canv island oh cany Island
it's a town oh man oh wow it's like it's
a town in England so yeah South End on
sea there's actually quite a bit more so
bivo begging for forgiveness now Sydney
has posted uh her response to his
response oh she replied that's right
you know what she's doing now she's
on her way to on a to a date for a
better man with whiter and bigger teeth
than you
right the bigger be her new man's like a
straight up piano she's got a mark could
play those things like a damn dude it's
like a grand like a
concert a baby gr that's
right I've just H up to the face off
with HS and xan and the girl turn up
with
B which is telling me that he's
obviously gone back with her last night
or she's gone back with him whatever way
around just a bit muggy really it's a
bit muggy isn't it it's a bit muggy I
got to listen to that again cuz I
actually I didn't understand I need a
little help was pretty rough I need a
little help you actually never guess
what I just had up to the face off with
HS andan okay and the girls turn up with
Vio NOP which is telling me that he's
obviously gone back with her last time
she so she told her that bivo went back
with her her friend told her that am I
hearing that right I don't know oh can
anybody there was something about a face
off is that what is that the Tik Tok
thing where like
I think they just had yeah they just
kiked they talked I see but a Kiki is a
happy thing right yeah so this isn't
wasn't a happy a Kiki is a party yeah
this oh it's a okay like a little maybe
they Kiki we don't know exchanging tea
it doesn't sound like a
Kiki your battery's running low oh
uhoh uh oh we're not plugged in Big Ups
to the
battery Big
Ups to
electricity Benjamin flank they got some
voltage yeah we love them love that
whatever yours is kind of just the
Beatles oh is it really yeah I'm picking
up a lot of Liverpool in there Big Ups
to Hey Jude yeah right thank you thank
you peace and love this is a serious
message he just did an update didn't he
I saw Ringo posted something oh he does
a peace in love every year on his
birthday really but I don't know if
that's what you're ref I just saw I I
was browsing and I saw that Ringo
uploaded something he's pretty active on
social media he puts out bangers like on
a regular video what do we got I'd love
to watch you post feet pick too did he
did he not just post something I posted
on from February 2nd I sent February
second okay Ringo here peace and love
everybody update
time wait this music might be the
Beetles is certainly uh spicy that's
true
I have nfts now oh no tell me that is
funny wait let me hear I got to hear
something but I'm still in the studio
I'm you know what yeah to
DIY Ringo come on you're new to the I'm
warning you I'm warning
you yeah so every year on his birthday
he says I want everybody please go
outside your house and at 12:00 p.m. say
peace and love PE peace and love for my
birthday peace and love peace and love
peace and love peace and love please
after the 15th of October no more fan
mail they're never going to die I think
I just don't think they're never yeah
they're crushing Eternal beings Paul's
Paul's looking healthy too how old are
they on tour yeah that's crazy
80 he's 80 I saw him at in 81 is he
really 81 yeah what about ringi Ringo's
83 godam he looks good what it's
crazy y' you're 83 Ringo Jesus I think
they definitely look better than like
Mick and Keith without a doubt dude R
looks children who smoked through their
teens and well into their 40s true I
mean that's remarkable good for him I
love
Ringo me too such a great character I
love the Beatles I really do I love the
Beatles with all my heart yeah I do too
love
them nothing like it big UPS Big Ups
beet Big Ups to The Beetles yeah big up
to Rango star and Big Ups to my
girlfriend the whole misunderstanding
yeah right cheers so here we are
um now
Cheyenne the cheating girl is clapping
back at Sydney what does she saying
there's more saying she should take her
man if she wanted to okay you tell me
Sydney or or Cheyenne this is the best
sticky bab girl what is this
outfit I'm sorry okay I'm sorry like
that's just not a flattering fit
dude I'm not saying anything about her
body or anything like that I'm just
saying girl that is not a way to dress
she got the back high like a she
doing a chubbing
talk she got the back high he's doing a
chub talk what the
all right go ahead
Cheyenne in it
that's a wild tell you one thing I can
take your M if I want to but lucky for
you baby girl I don't want to so let's
this chat say I want be respectfully no
you better be ready for the fight on
Thursday because I'm going to Bow Bow
your eye straight back into place also
be ready because you ain't ready to me I
was born ready periods period okay that
is one trashy ass girl right there my
friend dude that is like TR yeah I mean
you'd be hard pressed to find someone F
than that in the whole world straight
garbage
H MF probably hitting them up right now
oh I mean she just came out of nowhere
with that yeah what the like
first of all they were friends for 6
years so wait there's another one uh
this is a uh fresh 1 hour ago she posted
a new response to Sydney there's I'm
sorry this wasn't I just uploaded give
me one second I'll tell you right now
holy hell all right I can't wait the
description says Miss sell your man out
for a bit of clout oop could never be me
what damn dude she is is that what
happened Sydney sold her sold bivo out
that's what she says it's good to go oh
fantastic okay I was just sending this
while we were waiting yeah I I'll watch
it after also boring and you want to
create a boring story L about some ugly
man
keep that but respectfully babe I don't
want your man but I'm still going to
fight you for the principle of you cing
me out on the net calling me a bik
thinking you can chat my name not for
your man though even if I win or lose
you can still keep your dusty
man and by the way guys I'm a money girl
I was the director that part I don't
know what the she talking about
like genuinely I I don't know what she
said I feel like the thesis is just I'm
going to beat the out of you
basically F both of you guys
yeah I don't need you right but I'mma
beat the out of you why is she
threatening her damn trashy ass let me
see what the comments
are St wait they we call it STL wait STI
oh that's Sydney oh Sydney said STI
riddled bicycle yo oh that's hard that's
good dude Sydney Just Dropped a Bomb in
her lap 1 hour ago this is breaking you
guys breaking news this is Fresh Off The
okay Sydney girl you did it I'm liking
that if I'm logged in I am
yeah what is this comment why can't you
fight for your kid as much as you want
to fight a girl over a man I don't know
nothing about she she replied she
replied oh do you know what happens
off the app no I don't think so and that
is what happened babe so no do your
research and come with f they even write
that
out like that they come with
facts karma babe she said karma a
babe I'm sure you admitted to
sleeping with kipy and to be honest it's
all over F character and do both your
kids have the same dad just wondering
who is this replied and she replied who
is this nasty
little peace of work here yeah I don't
see her replying you
know interesting zipped her up it's not
just Sydney everyone knows you're a bike
is that is that an English thing where's
your top from Gorgeous never that
everyone gets a
ride wow that's the that's the the
implication what about when so who's
kipy yeah who is kipy we got to we got
to follow this R everyone talking about
being friends what about when Sydney
slept with Kipsy oh man hold the phone
hold the
phone I'm seeing it's British slang for
Town Bicycle everyone's had a ride oh a
Kipsy oh I love it no no B yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's pretty good I mean
in terms of like trying to insult women
yeah although she's definitely she
deserves it she deserves it man that I
mean she's a bicycle right
Olivia we don't know anything about
situation I know enough I know that she
seems like a pretty horrible friend
yeah we do know that M that we have
evidence of if she was my bicycle we
don't know if she was my bicycle I would
not be locking it
up yeah that thing would be available
for theft that thing is in eth sixth
gear dilapitated man Chain's falling off
the wheels are low yeah it's a
mess you can only really run it with
your running with two feet on the ground
you know like the BL
yeah if you hit a hill can Cruise
decently
but um what is this here uh cavcav
update I think Ryan meant to reply to
this comment but he could so this is a
pretty good theory I think he meant to
reply to this and say drink
responsibly whoa drinking game alert
take a drink every time Ryan says the
word
failure okay wellow so I mean what a
[Music]
oh God delicious this is a delicious
gamer Subs
mhm it's really good man that's good
that is refreshing it's really good yeah
all right so that was fun I mean we're
all up to date on bivo but hopefully the
story is going to keep developing dude I
cannot wait oh I've got my eye on it
where's the Mexican food
baby 34 are you good you need if you
need to go good man okay cool probably
have another hour okay you know how we
do it we're in here for the long run
we're actually already fun though I'm an
endurance champ man Ethan we're actually
already at 250 almost oh wow 3 hours
brother no how's that that's fun it
goes when you're having fun goes by
quickly it really has been I've
yeah I've been having fun with you
appreciate you absolutely you having me
on unfortunately I need to pee again
well guess I have a little TT that's
okay where is the food almost here
though where you going even get it can
we find out who Kipsy is do we know uh
Sam yeah we need yeah I'll be right back
maybe going and getting it right now I'm
going to gy with a z cuz she's not
there
so we're looking up this uh this new
character yeah now
huh I'm very invested Saga he has
158,000 followers kipy oh kipy is a big
social media star themselves yeah H I'm
seeing Sam just walked in with the food
so oh this is big Kipsy Army news okay
he has an
army The Kipsy Army yeah oh he's a
general they're going to come for poor
Cheyenne there or was Cheyenne the good
one or the bad one I forgety
yeah I have like the same
name he he definitely looks as though he
could be a part of this drama yeah yeah
fits the part he fits the
part there's there's a video titled I'm
not in
prison good okay good start yeah is it
Kip zy it's kipz Yore 99 is where we're
looking at on tick 99 kipy 99y hustle
kipy hustle okay let's take a
look I mean he's doing well oh Big Ups
oh big ups for sure this guy big UPS
this must be who they're talking about
he has another
account posting cheyen with him
is
really
oh oh this is all like copyright music
sh with him in another video this
morning I'm not too sure on the cause of
death but it was in her sleep guys I
cannot believe she served our country so
well and like I thought she was actually
going to reach 100 you know guys but
clearly not this guy has anti guys you
can live he's got an army dude he's got
an army it's the Army
arm Big Ups to
that I'm going to take I'm going to
close this well God bless him shout out
big UPS huge UPS to kid people saying
she
replied again like another another
another turn was that hit that
the girl I think they mean the other
girl replied in the comments CU I'm not
seeing Sydney post anything else another
one all right I'll leave that I'll leave
that to you to to investigate here um
Mark do you know what this means
somebody sent a Super Chat of
185 Q AR
what is that 185 Q was that the currency
they sent it uh oh katari money Kari wow
well they sent 184 or 185 of those
saying Mark needs to tell H3 to
collaborate with Harry Mack oh Harry
Mack do you know what that do you know
what this means yeah he's a very
talented freestyle rapper he's I would
say is like the best he's probably the
best living freestyle rapper huh oh I
think I know I he's on Tik Tok he's on
Tik Tok yeah that guy's crazy nuts he's
crazy I like his videos I think I follow
him yeah yeah he's good he's good he
walks around like Venice speach and like
just you know all all over the place
really definitely Big Ups Big Ups to Har
that watch you s is that something
special no it's just a Swatch oh for
real what do you Swatch Big Ups big up
SW I like anything Mark wears cuz Mark
dude Z is that you being diplomatic
or do you actually I'm going to Big I'm
going to plan a big wet one right on
your forehead wow
wait what is this kipy update whoa yeah
kipy so apparently there's a video with
Cheyenne in the oh thank you Sam
recently just
posted this is just deep dude bro these
people are so trashy mute it
though
that's what the wait is that
Cheyenne yeah on the right and then this
is this is the mystery uh Kipsy yeah and
if or the guy is kipy no the guy is
Kipsy wait oh she's saying saying okay
and if you go to this page he has videos
with her that's kipy in the back that's
Kipsy up there oh my God Cheyenne in the
bottom right this is honestly the worst
video on the internet it makes me so
uncomfortable I hate everything about it
sh I'm taking off my hoodie because he's
Jesus his looks like among us though
that's true
yeah holy you know what I mean I
just can't people people go oh English
people peaky blinders they look like uh
Killian Murthy nah bro they look like
this guy good God and
beo um by the way yeah bone Apple tea
everybody bone Apple tea oh thank
you and bu apppp everyone out there oh
they cut the burrito for you I hope
you're eating at the same time as us
they put french fries in
together okay big up from they put
french fries from read is it
reading yeah reading is a place reading
what I didn't see that on a menu french
fries inside the Dorito yeah thanks nice
it's kind of a fun
addition all I got oh man look like a
San Diego
thing dude this look at that t good
though that looks fire what is
the meat breakfast breakfast burrito
hell yeah is this the one that Ela
always orders from loo uh no this is
somewhere else no how's Ela doing look
good this is uh this is the truck he
look great yeah all as well she's Teddy
fresh kicking ass as
usual Teddy fresh is doing good he's
doing good the family's good oh Ethan
people are correctly pointing out that
Killian Murphy is not I just saw he's
Irish that's that's why he's handsome
that's yeah exactly you get that an
extraordinary I did you know what I'm
with that I think Irish people
are they got it going on I like the
Irish yeah
dude Irish are cool we love the Irish
here big UPS we hate the English Big Ups
the raw no we don't hate the English we
love the English hold on let me just
take a bite of this
burrito
looke godamn
[Music]
get C of culture my
friends
the greatest Empire the world has ever
known Colonial Empire
yeah right there never sets sure
does the Sun never sets I'll tell you
what nah I'm not going to go there I was
working on something but I didn't want
to execute it's usually for the best so
we have um well the Aiden Ross things
the head story so he should probably but
then again this Jessie Lee Peterson one
seems fun too but that's Evergreen I
guess eh yeah
definitely gu Peterson who's that I love
oh boy oh no if I answer it it's gonna
oh too much yeah it'll be the whole rest
of the show got it got it got it how's
Jordan Peterson
doing really he is he is not well really
up
yours what a surprise up yours woke more
he's uh beefing with Elmo right
now Elmo that wasn't real though right
the the one that that one wasn't real
but there was one of him talking about
Sesame Street it wasn't as
extreme he called like emo a communist
or something Jesus do I see it I mean
what what is this Sesame Street what is
this a commune like what do they do
there
sharing that sounds pretty communal to
me sounds like
said to me all
right so here is
um here's Aiden on stream with uh 21
Savage
okay and they're playing a card game
yeah high low I guess yeah and um
they're they're betting huge bets
hundreds of thousands of dollars
jeez and and so here here's the clip so
right before that it they were playing
like a basketball game and um add didn't
won a bunch of money dude Aiden
outplayed 21 yes holy Aiden must be
pretty good I think they played three
matches and they double or nothing three
times you're talking about a video game
yeah video
game um but yeah he was he was down
sorry about that well he was down at one
point I don't know if he was down do you
know love if he was down from that game
or if it wask I think yeah oh and this
is on kick now so they started with a
$1,000 bet they he lost No gambling dou
or nothing and then double thing again
actually yes that is what
happened yeah all the gambling's on kick
now I mean it's so it's kind of funny
the gambling company that was sponsoring
everybody on Twitch made
kick really yeah wow it's awesome right
wow it's really great the balls dude yep
wow all right so here it
is then I'll explain
bro
so what what everyone chooses a card and
whoever gets a Higher One first last
time don't be weird you confident don't
be weird you show first at the start of
the clip you'll see 21 on the left and
his friend his friend will point out a
card that is a high
there see that I did see that as soon as
Aiden looks
away but they know they're on camera
right uh I think he might think he's out
side the camera shot or something no way
no way so essenti the point is they're
cheating yeah oh man
and he's got to see the preview on his
screen right yeah um probably a laps of
judgment or it's fake or it's fake there
is speculation that there is fake it's
fake that wouldn't be
surprised show it first cuz I show it I
don't think they NE planned it but maybe
they weren't doing real confident don't
be weird you show it first I can't lose
well it's important to keep in mind that
21 is close with Drake just because
Drake is involved with steak and Aiden
so
yeah I need the max
win I know it huh say d da come on put
me in say da
D what you have
scratch but this one doesn't have a
scratch and it's a
king I don't think you would do that bro
this is where they realizing that the
the cards are marked not scratch bro so
people on
stream were making comments but he lost
like $300,000 or something right on that
so he was uh up 4 40 4 400,000 and then
I think he regained 300,000 so net loss
of 100K that's a lot of money it's a lot
that's a lot of
scratch Savage was down 400 and then
came up uh and Aiden ow him 2 50K by the
end of it Aiden owed him
250 look I'll show
you how does anyone like they could like
it could absolutely be fake right none
of it's verified there's no like
transaction records or anything no
they're all friendly so it doesn't seem
that serious could just be to like boost
each other's you know like come on
stream and we'll pretend like
we're could just be that yeah that 21
Savage was just goofing around 21
you
I don't know though to be honest it
seems I don't
know I'm going show you right here watch
right there's a little scratch that back
on to they're marked bro that back on to
what these are marked they left the
cards there don't leave the marked cards
that's 101 yeah that's the magician's
trick don't leave the leave the
trick yeah a little scratch right
there this seems like hear to be honest
you see
we can bu that same game back right now
like could they be wrong look right look
watch they have um oh I'm
sorry other way around Savage owed him
the 250 I just confirmed yeah it but I'm
not convinced that he was cheating is
this like totally confirmed what's
happening here no he he's still denying
it I don't think he cheated actually I'm
going to say denying it I don't think he
cheated I think his friend was just
they're on camera they're like yo you're
sitting with a friend and you're picking
like go pick that one doesn't mean
anything I'm going to send the other
video that people were talking about
okay good and also his friend was not
sitting close to the card so how would
he see the scratch from all the way back
there I guess that's true and anyone can
see the scratch the better
point I mean you might be it's obviously
subtle enough in their theory that he's
like right on it to find it so and then
why leave it there weird you know whose
cards were they if he they left them
there right I don't
know that one right there is a scratch
that one right there is a scratch man
get the out of am I oh people are
saying that there was a different part
where he switched the deck let me see
that yeah that's that's the Smoking Gun
if so 20 21 opens the deck straight from
the package and then he gives it to his
boy and then he gets it back a bit later
so that's allegedly where they changed
the decks okay scratch the card we'll
have to see
yeah so let's see what do we think about
Aiden Ross you a nice guy n okay not at
all he's a idiot he's a poopy
head there was a there was he was at a
crossroad at one point where he could be
redeemable but he did not walk down the
the path of redemption really he yeah he
went through a a breakup with a
long-term girlfriend and then became
very close with Tate and started
changing all of his views really oh no
oh yeah he likes sniff he's like
obsessed with um Andrew Tate he thinks
is his best friend or some wordship oh
no he he's being groomed by Andrew Tate
it's kind of interesting wrong person to
get to be a fan of he was one of the
five people that could visit Tate in
jail really yeah holy yeah yep I
know what the I you do I know you
wouldn't do that to me but I don't
know why the hold on let me see
this real quick I sent the video of
him switching the deck so what is this
yeah this one doesn't have it oh this is
at the point where where he's
confronting him about it the queen has
it see look look see the
six mm- see
21 hold on 21 Savage reaction is
throwing me off that dude's guilty as
yeah I mean if you I think it's
that's 21 right there
confirmed bro what huh what you want to
do oh it seems serious he goes what do
you want to do oh he cheated
oh and also AB isn't it true that he
gave the money back he did yeah oh then
he
cheated yeah he wouldn't I wouldn't do
that what the just get my B back at
2K well he made it seem like it was
somebody else on his team and he wasn't
he wasn't aware of it right someone else
on your team marked the cards for you
don't you have to know which cards to
pick right that's why
Point wow he's like I just go with damn
he's super lucky
yeah he has really good
luck that's a good burrito what is this
the french fries are really good
actually throwing me
off didn't right here revealed you
definitely knew it was
up back back at 2K bro listen I'm going
to be honest chat it's not his cards I
know he's not going to do that to
me Jesus this kind of weird energy in
there like someone playing basketball in
the back what the so then okay
that's 21 Savage I I actually like his
music he's got some nice some hits he
got some he's got some bangers 21 yeah
my boy can you do something for me 21
you
right what's that one song that's that I
love it's um a lot yeah dude that song's
awesome people were it's got mad E40
energy they were saying how much have
you lied a lot how much have you scammed
a lot M no
y it's so E40 coded I love that um so
then there was another
wrinkle uh Aiden confirmed that he did
pay him back okay if you I'm sorry if
you want to go to Discord real quick I
sent the video of them swapping decks
okay good let's see oh
allegedly so I find it how is he going
to deny it after he paid him back and
right and he didn't even protest
really yeah he just said there was like
yep no he's not going to scam me trust I
know how to play that why are they
already talking about
scamming do we have like a table where
we can sit why a
shat someone in shat said he's going to
scam you and he said no we won't oh
they're already saying 30 yeah nah he's
not going to scam me trust I know how to
play that simple yeah but why are
they already saying dirty he hasn't done
anything yet do we have like a table
where we could sit like this a little
circle like a little circle of a
table here
so he handed the pack off
yeah put table War hry where's the pack
yeah the pack is out of frame he just
opened it and gave it to his friend yeah
I love the caption hand it off to one of
his goons true I mean that's pretty
accurate I don't give a
high card yeah the Goon then hands
21 Savage back that is funny that was
weird why would he hand it to his friend
to Market no not to Market he probably
gave him a fake deck or a pre-marked
deck mhm or that yeah that's what I he
said I give you the Fresh Deck I give
you the freshy yeah you give me back the
Marky yeah
exactly these are experienced cheaters
actually is what I'm seeing I don't know
if 21 Savage going to be welcome back at
the card games after
this oh
man look at how close he's looking oh
yeah he's looking right right up oh he
did that behind his back show it first
cuz I show it first last time dude they
are ABS Lely that's so corny why
you going to cheat your boy in cards man
and like like cameras are on you dude so
dumb oh jeez okay so wait now can we
look at Aiden showing him the the the
the marked card again sure cuz cuz cuz I
want to see his reaction now because
that's so clear
it's so clear yeah I mean he well yeah
his reaction was straight guilt this is
what I saw let's see is this what I oh
this is a different clip oh yeah this is
another one where he's like people
thought he was signaling and we spoke
for like 20 minutes and he was just
saying to me like I got the wrong people
around me and and and I and I'm
sorry about that bro it's just flat out
embarrassing and I'm not with
that at all and you know I I'm sorry man
and all that all that stuff and then
he's like send me your wire and fall
make sure you have the wire in the
morning he came came through on it I got
the full 250 the $250,000 which is what
we agreed on before starting the car
game and before starting the dice right
and the monkey so we agreed on $250,000
and uh cuz that was his buy out it was
originally 4K but I was like you want to
buy out and then yeah so he gave me
$250,000 sent to my sensiz um it's
not cap I literally have the wire uh
proof but I got to blur out all
information and um so I'll show
proof in a second let me send it yo uh
pris I'm going to send you the the proof
of the wire and do me a favor and just
literally blur out all the personal info
please he was already like yo for the
next stream let's let me take do that
bro I'll take you where I'm from we'll
walk around the streets and and
we'll do some cool so I was like
all right it and look at you guys
gassing it like bro like stop bro like
but anyways so he uh he said he's down
to do that and I was never
following him on Instagram I was never
following him on Instagram people said
that I'm following me going follow me I
was never I was never following on
Instagram to be good
with um but yeah why are you not
following him follow your boy cap I
swear to God you're going to get set up
I'm going to be all on stream I'm G tell
this when I go do an ey they go to his
hometown around that's what everyone's
saying some random dude just come and
steal kidnap him he's going to be like
uh that video of soldja boy in the hood
oh my God one of the best videos of all
time I don't like this guy yeah he sucks
although like if like the cut of his jib
if they're fake it that's super funny
like if they do fake it where he gets
abducted W
amazing okay so
um let's see
now 21 okay he's selling merch now what
do you make of this 21 Savage put out
some fresh merch Dice and cards no
way no way yep metal dice
weighted they're like weighted on one
side
okay so that how' they make that so
fast that thickens the plot a little bit
yeah that's why people think it's fake
too I mean he could just be doing a goof
also that's true trying to own it right
right but then there's more there's a
whole separate situation so next what
happened is this guy Playboy
cardi apparently famous rapper
yep um big deal shortly after the Stream
yeah with 21 Savage Aiden Ross and play
booy cardi had a streaming collaboration
that ended
badly Playboy cardi is private and
rarely does interviews or makes
appearances so him coming on Aiden's
stream was a big deal Aiden claims he
paid Playboy cardi $2 million and a new
Ferrari to come on his
stream that's insane right is Playboy
cardi arrived 2 hours late and they
exchanged awkward small talk and then
party left just over 5
minutes after 5 minutes holy really
that's iconic wow with a bag of money
I'm with Playboy Aiden Ross and
he's wearing a mask the whole time and
it's super dark in this room what the
hell y he obviously has no respect for
Aiden I mean that's what's happening
here he's like thanks for the money
idiot I don't give a apparently
Cardi's people shoose the location too
so they set up the kind of my gosh
what is with this lighting yeah that's
$2 million lighting right there that's
right Aiden look what an idiot you are
look at you wow such a mark appearance
fee 2 million in a Ferrari yeah wow also
was supposed to get him a jet back a
private jet back wherever he came from
wherever he's
going yo big UPS to cardi I want to see
a
chat so this is a $2 million shot right
here finally about time it's that time
Chad so is he here I don't know what's
happening oh he hasn't walked in yet no
this is bad
content what do you mean do you see it
he's like what exciting stuff people go
Mr Beast waste money step aside you have
a new waster in
town yall want to react to some
damn
it bro drinking out of five can cups at
once oh so how was the G why you doing
that so his Peak viewers in this stream
was 487 th000 viewers I'm just sitting
in a dark room 400 did it Peak when he
was there or before when he was there I
think really and it averaged 300K over 3
and 1 half hours averaged yeah Jesus
Christ Christ bro why are you
drinking out of 1 2 3 four five cups at
once fing dumb what's the advantage here
buddy it's a flex it's a huge Flex like
bro I one cup bro I'm on that five
cup grind come on man you're over here
drinking
that the thing keeps falling out I don't
know if it was another
accident it fell out of here trying to
think but nothing happens both times it
fell out of there can I get a few more
cups please we always we get cued out
you want something to drink I'm good
dude I've got I've got my gamer Subs I'm
loaded and rocked Up's up that's
what's up yeah all right
so let me fast forward to when he comes
right there right there right here he
just shook his hand let me go back he's
wearing gloves too dude what are you got
to be kidding me you doing bro this is
embarrassing nice to officially meet you
why is he meeting him like he's Al
Capone what the is this got
watching the
helmet this is the camera right here
right here they waiting for you for two
hours bro they just they love you so
much bro and they're you know they feel
amazing you're here now I love you and
he doesn't like talk amazing
here that Ross chat you guys got to
understand bro the stream it's your
first time doing the stream isn't it mhm
yeah I got you bro card's talking like a
like a shy like 5-year-old yeah and
Aiden's just this is weird yo if you
guys want to uh actually matter of fact
I got you
bro so check this bro I got some cash
for you yeah a little gift for me to you
why you paying him already cuz he's
getting nervous you know it's a good
amount of money in here you know okay a
lot amount of money in here okay I got
you bro um from me to you he does not
care yeah I got you bro he does not care
this is very weird what happens here you
do hugs you have a little hug uh what
okay do we know that that was playy
cardi at all is happen so there's one
point uh where he gets close to the
camera cuz Chad's saying that's not him
and I guess from his eyes they could
tell that it's him oh
really they did some in wearing a mask
it's the same exact thing he was wearing
at the Grammys too oh so it's pretty
unique is it a unique mask seems like it
not a superhero you want to take a
seat you want to take a seat I'm good
thank you though appreciate that
okay dude he got the bag and left
basically I'm like
59 that's are you why is there no lights
in this place this is weird
really I might be talking the 59 I don't
know put the camera up we don't need to
be in the dark anymore this is let me
see real quick this is nuclear so
uncomfortable this is
nuclear the shittiest content
that that's not Kanye
ninja God
idiot this is this is what you need to
do with
life I you're you know what you're
absolutely right no lights no lights no
face right minimal words yeah air
conditioning on1
million bag of cash someone playing
basketball in the
background scratching cards let's go
yeah yeah yeah one day you got to get me
right though yes yeah
yes yeah wow what's to do with the mask
that's just something you've been
rocking with il I I mean this you don't
see interactions this awkward that's
really like this is a rare rare he's got
both hands on his
waist and they're standing up such a
bizarre
pose yeah it's like a dad
watching the grill or some yeah but
this is the mask I guess is he like
socially awkward Playboy cardi no he's a
normal guy normal interviews with him
okay but the thing the the reason he's
so hyped up right now is because he
hasn't dropped the album in like four
years or something like that see on on
YouTube if you just stop posting
people stop caring about you yeah I
guess in the music world you disappear
and they just want you more more more
momentum and addin tweeted like music
2024 so that's why this got so much
traction because all of his fans they
thought he was going to drop the album
or some
sh people probably pissed so you going
to step into this stream and drop some
hot
fresh
turd
poopsies instead we got this oh really
yes which is a hot fresh sh frankly it's
nice it is um oh really all right well C
look if you guys got questions for for
him we don't got him for too long what
is that let me know who is that c just
clapping really loud why I don't
know I don't know Chad says this is
worse than Bill Burr yeah way worse yeah
I sat down I had two conversations with
that man don't take you know what I mean
don't put don't compare
me you let me know right now I really do
appreciate you coming though for real
for real I know you don't ever do
like this and it means a lot to me
you're here it means so much to me that
you met me in this dark room with a mask
on after I paid you $2 million and won't
communicate with me at all the easiest
lick of all time yeah dude what a
sucker Aiden is you know what I
love it's the thing I love about this is
just how meaningful it is you
tell most about this thing it is
powerful moment for aen God damn that's
meaningful thank you shouts to kick
again for making this possible and
I know Eddie's in here watching it's
like he's already wrapping it up
yeah he's like thanks anybody here's the
cash kick appreciate you having
us um you working on the album though
right love you love you thank you thank
you that you could probably tell if
that's him or not from The Voice wait
talk real quick love love love you thank
you so much for
everything 2024
music thank you Aiden Ross too for
Hospitality uh got you bro got you got
you bro hey anything else you need
listen Dark Room anything else I can get
you if I'm what did you get exactly if
I'm a house if I'm a guest at someone's
house the first thing I expect is
electricity and and you know I mean
what Hospitality e you got the lights on
man appreciate the hospitality dude
absolutely that's the least I could do I
appreciate it important that we have
like you know good bonds with the
streamers Eddie we got to sign him full
time to
kick a little bit you know it's like um
he's meeting his biological dad for the
first
time he doesn't know what to say
how there you go you playing games and
video games oh my God no no you got
play sick like Angry you play video
games no sick sick that's dope dude hell
no oh can you do me a
favor could you ask people to uh follow
me on Kick what oh my why would what
this is an
embarrassment this is an embarrassment
like he has five minutes with him he
goes hey can you give me a shout out on
my own stream he has like a humiliation
fetish yeah this is like the most
awkward make a wish I've ever
seen really yeah bro card if you don't
want to do make a wish then don't
participate you know give show these
poor kids a good
time follow
Aiden thank you bro thank you so much
follow little Aiden that's going to
become
useful he goes thank you bro oh is he
sweating inside Aiden bro why do you
guys think it's not him it's obviously
him bro y are trolling it's obviously
him I don't say OB back on the hips
there Aiden that's a good it's
good okay this is the weirdest video on
inter you excited for it if you go back
just a little bit to like 449 he like
clears his throat in the mic yeah it's
disgusting Big lugie or something who
cardi or Aiden cardi right here oh I
think it's Aden oh think is Aiden maybe
thank you so
much oh was
Aiden I think it was Aiden yeah nasty
bro obviously
him it's almost over so how's the album
coming along it's coming along good you
excited for it so excited damn bro
anything you could tell us tell the
people mind BL mind
blowing my best BL mind BL my very best
is is is he good is he talented I don't
know anything about him he's part of the
modern sort of trap Renaissance and he's
yeah good okay got hits was he just
treating him like rembrand over here
like people are salivating for his new
album I well I guess they are yeah the
Beetles actually insane it's insane is
this a snuff film someone asked it seems
like it definitely yeah murder dude we
might be watching Aiden Ross be murdered
yes once again thank you for everything
and I love you I you know I wouldn't be
here with anybody so thank you again
your cloes on the mic he's bailing
scratching oh damn bro like it's just
crazyer actually here he's like
Darth
Vader backing into the shadow what is
this and Aiden is like the worst bootleg
Luke Skywalker wish
ever hly didn't think it was going to
happen bro I didn't think it was going
to happen I know you're very busy you're
locked in the music and stuff so I
didn't think it was going to happen well
really almost basically didn't how was
your day looks like you just want to
sweep
Stakes how was your
day anyway you play video games or
what's up so what do you do for
fun 2024
music he's out
you right now yeah all right let me mute
real quick he he's like yo what the
bro oh oh man what a Los wow someone's
got to boost the Shadows on that video
so we can get a good look true you know
let's go ahead and boost those Shadows
so that's Aiden that's what happened but
then 21 Savage calls in cuz he found out
he paid yeah there we are
hey yeah this is the new look I've
decided to implement for the
stream uh it's just more modern yeah
aesthetically lighting is kind of like
played out can we can you also speak in
a more monotone voice good yeah also can
you turn off Mark's mic I prefer if you
can't hear the guest really just Zach
yeah and can we put One mic up next to
the air conditioning
unit you pay Mark two million two 202 do
we have the cash for Mark the duffel bag
full of
cash app bring me the the the suitcase
full of gamer Subs yeah MH yeah here
we'll bring it out here bro hey you've
done so much for me bro thank you so
much for everything you've done for me
man you really deserve this 2024 P 202
for music that's right music
yeah yeah 400,000 people watching I
don't play video games bro for real sick
all right so now that this happened 21
finds out that he paid card2 million and
then he gets upset he's like you didn't
pay me oh wow so here's that call
happening what an idiot he's are
gambling embarrassing this guy
is such an embarrassment Jes I need the
max win
Super
Bro what a loser he didn't get the full
mil a million he stop it bro
no bro why the you ain't pay me bro
that's crazy bro you you're I ain't
going to lie bro I ain't going to lie
bro that's up bro brother I was
going to buy you cars and what the
do you
mean bro2 million how cool do you feel
when like all these cool people hang
around with you literally because you
pay them like it couldn't be more
obvious In This Moment Like how cool do
you feel he's like no we're still homies
I'll buy you cars he is just getting
treated like a little yeah
basically he's such a mark why didn't
you pay me man the bro p a
milliones bro he didn't get paid
that bro you PID for six minutes no I
didn't well I kind
of I just seen you get him a bag of cash
okay but bro guess what he's not bro
trust me you and I are going to make
more money together like this okay
you're going to make you and you're
going to make more money like this he
well yeah bro we got to have a talk when
I see you
bro bro you and I will make more money
together than him and he just made in 6
minutes I promise so I can't tell how
serious this call is but uh right it's
funny it is funny Aiden said that uh he
wanted to sign a deal with cardi for
like 30 million and that he messed up by
leaving when he did no he was not 30
million for what what is Aiden Ross what
a kick thing yeah a kick really
streaming thing they after that
performance they want to pay him 30
million Christ I need the max win I the
max Queen it's like the crazy thing is
though it's like as embarrassing as that
whole charade is the viewership you know
it was a spectacle yeah is nuts um
something's working so we're at 4:30 so
we can do the Jesse Lee Peterson or we
can save that but we've been going for a
while right Dan yeah we're at uh we're
at 3:30 we've done 3:30 we've did both
of our headline stories wow do we want
to just quickly see JY Lee Peterson
found out about oral I think it's it
needs its time let me just give the
people a taste I won't react okay okay
don't react so we had a women's form
last night and one of the things that
came up we talked about a whole bunch of
stuff the ladies brought up that you
know how we were talking about or STX on
the radio and I was saying the guy that
said uh kind of see he had that racism
clip yeah he's super R he hates black
people oh right yes yes I know okay yeah
he he's he is a weird
interesting dude being gay and being
black is
different men should not be doing that
because it's like eating out of a trash
can oh yeah right we can't forget I'll
never forget that you have the dirt
coming out blood all the people say
stuff yeah whoa disease bro are you what
are you are you going down on your girl
after someone blasted in her coming
out have you ever heard of a shower I
mean it's dirt and garbage other
people's I tell you just dust and dirt
out of that thing man it's spilling out
y'all eat it out not y'all but y'all men
are doing that it is gross uhhuh um the
lady said that the ladies said that to
help women
I need to mention that a lot of women
are now
doing oress to men but not or do they
call or say men stuff wait what wait
when the women do it to the men yeah
either way I think it is called other
things what the
what is happening he's the man I
had to correct you it's not now D
looking over one of The Producers what
do you call an oral oral the women are
doing oral these days is that right you
long
time and so knew and so I asked the Ladi
were there many women that knew about
this and I was stunned at the answer I I
thought it was like a thing what
there's a lot of out
there I didn't know normal women did
that to men what most most women are
these days hold the phone dude
this dude are you serious what a
loser this bro is desperate not to get
his dick sucked how cool is this
guy no don't suck my
dick only a would suck my dick what
a dude where do you find such losers and
put them in a room bro look at you this
is just look at you he looks dis these
days this is a man who knows about oral
sex better this than shooting up his
high school though I'll say that yeah
that's true that's a if if it's the
choice between the two I'll take this
definitely take
this I knew that normal women were doing
that to men as as men are doing that to
women yeah I thought I thought it was
normal yeah in high school they would
say like well not in high school but
some of my high school friends would say
they'll they would say I'm Christian I
won't have sex with you but I will why
does he sound like that who are not in
high school but some of my high school
friend like I'm not in high school but
the high schoolers that I hang out with
he he's talking like an alien
impersonating a human being listen to
this they would say I'm Christian I
won't have sex with you but I will I'm
Christian I would't have
this what are you doing that what what's
the name for well there's various names
but name that we can mention on oh
there's not a decent name I mean you
already me just or oral sex using your
basic oh it's the same when a woman
doing it to a man called or yeah yeah
it's not specific exciting though
Jesse's getting sex ed right here on the
radio so it's pretty exciting we'll get
into that we have a whole lot to watch
he's having like a re oh man taking this
BR he's like hold on nobody's ever gone
down on me what's that
about these days could be the smell Jess
could be the try and watch her swallow
oh why did I say that again wait that
did sound like you Dan I know her
swallow Dam come on wait it sounds like
keemstar try and watch her swallow this
Mark rier wait is that noted did no no
no now I'm just Dan saying
something about swallowing I don't know
Play It Again Zack what that
is try and watch her swallow okay I hear
it now I hear it clearly d uh one uh
generous donation from woik said Ethan
crew and Mark peace and love I'm trans
and I've grown up lived in what is
usually remembered as the KKK capital of
Missouri I felt lost on community until
I found age3 the show and making music
are my mental comforts Mark watching you
play led to building my Loop rig oh hey
nice
hey we love you I love to hear that I'm
I'm so happy you're here welcome well I
have always been a huge fan of this this
operation and it it's it makes me happy
to be on here too we're all happy to be
with this that was a good episode we had
fun yeah we had fun really covered some
good ground oh is this the real hold on
okay so this is the
this is what you asked for um Mark oh
bringing up the uh Shadows oh nice oh
you can actually see quite a bit more so
where are they there's a chain leak
fence behind them like did he really
make him some Warehouse he asked for an
industrial Vibe oh God so it's kind of
cringe how he's trying to make himself
look so mysterious dude set up in like a
hanger it's incredibly cring probably
freezing cold in there
yeah wow with his little silver
gloves Aiden you are such an idiot bro
yeah but we had a lot Warcraft character
happy 2024 everybody so Mark anything
what are you up to is there anything you
want to tell the people about uh what am
I up to I'm um you see me around playing
stuff and live streaming here and there
mark reier everywhere m a r c re e b i l
l e t and um yeah I'm um I'm going to be
touring uh I'm playing Asia in March
first time I'm doing Tokyo and India and
Indonesia Thailand excited about that so
you have fans in those places I think
we're kind of like finding out if I do
oh interesting you know that'll be
interesting putting me in a few
festivals over there and then we'll see
yeah and then I'll announce Europe and
North America tours also in March or
April so keep your eyes peeled it's
going to be he's coming A few big boys
yeah and let us know we'll plug it
because Oliver tree he calls in the show
every time he wants us to plug something
I hate him he's annoying could you
maybe just plug my dates like when he
calls in and asks you just plug my dates
that's funny we'll do that are your
tickets on or not yet not yet okay so
let me know okay and I'll I'll I'll tell
everyone okay sounds good yeah um well
guys this was great welcome everybody
happy Monday my house flooded I'm trying
not to think about that yeah I guess you
have to go deal with that sounds like an
entire floor is covered in basically one
inch of water lovely I remember him
saying 2 in say one in one in one inch
say one inch yep but it spr all over the
roof everyone drink out of five cups
true flex on the haters my friends yeah
um we shall be back on Wednesday
remember everybody Thursdays our new see
you next Thursdays our our members uh
podcast is on Thursday now so tomorrow
there'll be nothing and we'll be back on
Wednesday for a action-packed excellent
show and until then be good stay safe
and thanks for
[Music]
watching let's do it yeah
H3 yeah let's do a chorus
[Music]
yeah